Ihr hört CRE Technik Kultur Gesellschaft mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zur 194. Ausgabe unseres kleinen Programms hier.
Das schließt mich ein das schließt Euch ein und das schließt auch unseren heutigen Gast ein, der schon ein paar mal da war. Nämlich Andreas, Andreas Bogk, Hallo.
Hallo.
Ja Andreas, wenn du kommst würde man sicher - würde man ja meinen jetzt müssten wir uns mal wieder über Programmiersprachen unterhalten oder Compilersysteme oder so.
Oder Cryptofoo oder...
Ja genau. Das sind doch eigentlich deine Hobbys.
Eigentlich schon aber so ab und zu braucht man halt was anderes und es ist ja auch in aller Munde...
Schön gesagt, ja. Es ist in aller Munde, was ist in aller Munde? In aller Munde ist Bier.
Jetzt wo wir das aufnehmen ist ja auch grad noch Fußballeuropameisterschaft, da fließt grad noch besonders viel durch die Kehlen.
Ja wir wollen über Bier reden und das hat auch den Grund, nämlich den Grund dass das Thema Bier bei dir so ein bisschen durch den Hobbykeller fließt neuerdings, da frag ich mich natürlich: "Wieso eigentlich?"
Ja ich bin infiziert worden mit dem Brauvirus vor 2 Jahren auf einer Konferenz in Belgien natürlich. Belgien eines der großen Bierländer dieses Planeten.
Wo eine der Vortragenden abends dann noch einen 3-Stunden-Workshop machten. Das war die Brucon und das war ein Brauworkshop und das hab ich mir angeguckt und dachte mir: "Das kann ich auch".
Aber warst du denn da überhaupt?
Das war halt so Standard IT Sicherheitskrams so wo man halt so hingeht als Hacker.
Brucon.
Brucon. B R U
Also da ging...
Da gehts um irgendwie, die ist halt in Brüssel und deswegen heißt sie Brucon.
Achso B R U con nicht Brewcon.
Genau, genau es ging gar nicht ums Bierbrauen, es ging eigentlich um Computersicherheit, aber abends gab's halt Bier.
Verstehe
Na dem kann man in Belgien nicht so recht entgehen.
Nee nee, also man muss da natürlich auch ein bisschen offen dafür sein. So als gestandener Pilstrinker guckt man erstmal komisch, aber wenn man sich erstmal darauf eingelassen hat, dann gibt's da wirklich ne unglaubliche Vielfalt sehr leckerer Biere.
Wobei ich ja finde, dass das belgische Bier schon mehr so in Richtung Weinbrand geht.
Ja das hat was Likörmäßiges, das hat auch damit zu tun, dass tatsächlich Brände verboten waren, also Schnaps war verboten von 1910 bis glaub ich in die späten 70er und die Leute natürlich trotzdem das Bedürfnis hatten betrunken zu werden, also gab es eine erhöhte Nachfrage nach etwas stärkerem Bier und so ist es gekommen das die belgischen Biere heute immer noch größtenteils 8 9 10 manchmal 11 12 Prozent haben.
Krass. So und dann was fand da statt auf diesem Workshop?
Na wir haben Bier gebraut. Also was man so tun muss. Ähm, das Malz mahlen, einmaischen...
Aber es war schon Teil dieser  Konferenz oder war das noch mal so separat...
Jaja das war natürlich sozusagen im Rahmen des Entertainment und Abendprogramms in einem Zelt vor dem Veranstaltungsort und ähm...
Also so nach dem Motto "Hacker interessiert ja immer alles!"
Genau, genau. Und Bier geht immer gut und dann können wir auch mal Bier machen.
Okay... Und dann? ... Hast du das Licht gesehen.
Dann hab ich das Licht gesehen...
Das ist ja die die Belgier sind ja auch aufm Camp immer dadurch aufgefallen, dass sie große Mengen Gulden Draak angeschleppt haben.
Ja.
das belgische Starkbier.
Mhmh.
Und ja so bin ich nach Hause gekommen und hab selber angefangen Bier zu machen und war relativ schnell damit erfolgreich und festgestellt das ist das macht Spaß das ist ein toller Nerdsport und ....
Zu hause?
und man hatte leckeres Bier. Ja zu Hause.
So in der Küche?
Genau, genau da ist meine Küche ein bisschen größer und ich habe glücklicherweise einen Wok-Brenner, was die Sache erheblich vereinfacht.
die meisten Leute fangen mit Einkochern an. Also so fertige Dinge elektrisch beheizt, passen ungefähr 20 Liter rein die Oma immer fürher verwendet hat um Marmelade einzukochen oder was auch immer. Kirschen Sauerkirschen und die kann man relativ leicht umfunktionieren als Bierzubereitungsgerät.
Man brauch noch ein bisschen mehr Gerätschaften, aber das ist so das Kerndings. Man braucht'n Topf und man braucht'n Weg Feuer drunter zu machen.
Mh
Also so viel braucht man ja eigentlich nicht weil die ja also kann ja eigentlich nicht so schwer sein, weil das gibt's ja irgendwie schon immer oder?
Tatsächlich gibt's Bier schon immer, also Bier lässt sich nachweisen Anfang mit den allerersten sesshaften Kulturen, das waren die Sumerer,
die Brot gebacken haben und die auch Bier gemacht haben. Und das also Backen von Brot und das Produzieren von Bier ist technologisch sehr ähnlich und offensichtlich wurde das auch relativ früh entdeckt.
Und deswegen also wo immer Brot gebacken wurde, wurde auch Bier gemacht, schon immer.
Ach, was macht diese Nähe zueinander aus?
Naja, also man man nimmt Getreide man macht es klein und gibt Wasser dazu und macht's dann irgendwie warm und dann wenn man nicht ganz so viel Wasser nimmt und es ein bisschen wärmer macht ist es hinterher Brot und wenn man bisschen mehr Wasser nimmt und es nicht ganz so warm macht ist es hinterher Bier. Also das ähm
Mh
Ähnelt sich schon sehr. Getreide klein machen und nass machen und was mit Wärme und dann ...
Fragt man sich so ein bisschen was zuerst da war ja? Also das klassische... die Henne Ei Vergleich der trifft jetzt nicht so richtig. Aber zuerst Getränke machen oder zuerst Brot?
Das ist ne verdammt gute Frage, ich denke es ging erstmal darum, also zu Jäger-und-Sammler-Zeiten haben die Leute natürlich angefangen Körner zu sammeln und zu essen. Und das immer bisschen mühselig, weil man ganz schön drauf rumkauen muss, also versucht man die klein zu stampfen, dann wenn man die klein gestampft hat, dann ist es ganz schön trocken und dann liegt also nahe so eine Art Porridge zu machen so'n Getreidebrei.
Mhmh
Und wenn man den halt zu lange rumstehen lässt dann wird's Bier und wenn man nicht will, dass es zu lang rumsteht, deswegen nah ans Feuer tut, dann wird's Brot. Also was da ausschlaggebend ist, man könnte jetzt natürlich spekulieren: "Ja ohne Bier wären die Leute nie sesshaft geworden." Aber es hat sicherlich genauso viel mit dme Brot zu tun wie mit dem Bier am Ende.
Aber wodurch wird es denn Bier?
Ich meine...
Im Wesentlichen durch die Fermentation. Also Getreide ist ja erstmal stärkehaltig und manche erinnern sich vielleicht noch an ihren Biologieunterricht, wenn man anfängt auf Brot rumzukauen, fängt es irgendwann an süß zu schmecken, weil Stärke ja aneinander hängende Zuckermoleküle sind.
Und aus dem Zucker wiederum kann die Hefe Alkohol machen, das ist dieser Vergärungsprozess. Also Getreide Stärke klein schnippeln in Zucker, den Zucker dann durch Hefen zu Alkohol werden lassen, das ist so der Bierproduktionsprozess, ganz grob, fast.
Aber wo kam denn da die Hefe her, wenn die erstmal nur Getreide und Wasser zusammengemanscht haben?
Na das ist so wie in jeder Nerdküche wenn man das Zeug lange genug stehen lässt, fängt es an zu leben.
Also du meinst die Pilze haben sich da sozusagen einfach selbst... eingefangen.
Also so ein bisschen von den Zusammenhängen schon gesehen. Aber relativ lange wurde tatsächlich mit spontaner Gärung gearbeitet, spontaner Fermentation.
Irgendwann entdeckte man dann, dass dieser Schleim der beim Biermachen oben aufschwimmt und später wieder unten, dass das Hefe ist. Also genau die Würfel Bäckerhefe die man kennt sind im Prinzip das ein bisschen getrocknet.
im Mittelalter sagte man Berme dazu das war der Fachbegriff und wenn man den ins nächste Bier reingießt, dass es dann schneller geht mit dem neuen Bier.
Aber noch heute werden in Belgien Biere teilweise spontan vergoren, also sie kommen einfach in große offene Pfannen und dann wartet man bis es anfängt zu gammeln und dann tut man ins Fass und dann wird Bier draus.
Hm
Das ist also ohne bewusste Hefezugabe?
Genau genau die kommt einfach aus der Luft.,
Das heißt das Bier definiert sich ohnehin einfach aus der Bakterienvielfalt aus der Region und ist von daher dann anders je nachdem wo man grad so ist.
Ja teilweise schon, man kann sich natürlich, also Hefen sind keine Bakterien ja, da muss man schon mal aufpassen, Hefen sind Hefen, das ist so was eigenes.
Und man kann sich aber auch Bakterien einfangen, da wird das Bier sauer. Und gesäuerte Biere sind lange Zeit sehr populär gewesen.
So ne Flasche Berliner Weiße steht vor dir, da sind tatsächlich auch Bakterien die dann ne Rolle spielen, die dann für die Säuerung sorgen.
Ja
Und die Hefe die für den Alkohol sorgt. Und auch die belgischen Biere, diese spontan fermentierten Biere, die sammeln tatsächlich auch Bakterien ein und in der Regel sind das dann Sauerbiere.
Hm
Also Pilze um ...
Jaaaaaa,  mhmhm die Biologen schlagen mich jetzt wenn ich ja sage, aber ...
Wieso?
Es sind eher Pilze als.. naja Hefen sind Hefen, das ist was eigenes.
Aha
Also es sind ist aber gedanklich eher an Pilzen dran als an Bakterien, ja.
Ok, Einzellige Pilze heißt es hier.
Einzellige Pilze genau.
Ok.
Ok das versteh ich, also das heißt eigentlich wollten die Leute nur Körner fressen?
Mh
Und aus praktischen Erwägungen sind sie dann irgendwann dazu gekommen das alles zusammen zu rühren und auf einmal hat's geblubbert und dann haben sie das mal getrunken und ich weiß nicht was kommt denn zu diesem Zeitpunkt überhaupt bei raus also?
Also naja damals war das wahrscheinlich so eine Art vergorener Getreidebrei so wie in Porrridge mit Alkoholgeschmack, das warn so wohl das erste Bier. Bis die Technik die der Filtration erfunden wurde, das Abläutern. Was bestimmt auch noch mal ein bisschen gedauert hat.
Mhmh
Das heißt dann nimmt man dann die ganzen Feststoffe wieder raus und übrig bleibt
die Flüssigkeit
Ja eigentlich der Saft...
Genau genau
Und dann ist man schon wahrscheinlich relativ nah an dem dran, was man heute als Bier kennt.
Mhmh
gut wenn du dich dann jetzt sozusagen an deine eigene Pfanne gesetzt hast, was hast du dann da genommen, also ich meine was was war also was nimmt man jetzt so für die Ex. die ersten Experimente, was hat dich da der Workshop gelehrt?
Und entweder holt man sich das schon geschrotet oder mit einer Malzmühle dazu. Also geschrotet ist so zu sagen grob klein gemacht. Es darf nicht zu fein sein, weil sonst klappt das mit dem läutern nicht. aber zum läutern kommen wir ja später.
Also kurz fest zu halten. Malz ist quasi leicht angekeimtes Getreide, was man dann durch Hitzezuführung wieder davon abgehalten hat weiter zu keimen?
Genau genau so ist das.
Und dabei entwickelt es welche Qualität?
Also wenn man so einen Keimling hat, das erste was er tut ist jede Menge dieses Enzyms zu produzieren. Diese Amylase und die ist in der Lage die Stärke zu Zucker zu spalten. Das ist das was wir wollen.
mhh ok verstehe. Das heißt man nutzt eigentlich so diesen Wachstumseffekt der Pflanzen aus?
Mehr oder weniger ja. So also den natürlichen Prozess mit dem die Stärke wieder zu Zucker umgewandelt wird.
Und wo kriegt so ein Malz?
Also so die komplette Betriebsausstattung einer Mälzerei. Auf dem technischen Stand von vor 100 Jahren und beim Unterwelten e.V. gibt's Führungen. Nicht mehr lange, weil demnächst fangen die Bauarbeiten an.
Ah wo ist die?
Das muss man sich angucken.
Ich glaub das ist die in der Bessemer Straße wo das Kitkat mal ne Weile saß.
Kreuzberg. Oder ist Steglitz oder wo...
Das ist Bessemer Straße ist da irgendwo im Westen. Ich weiß nur, dass es weit ist.
Mhmh
So die alte genau in Pankow gab's noch Mälzereien, das ist da wo jetzt die Eigentumswohnungen gebaubt werden.
Ja
Momentan ist die Situation ein bisschen traurig. Die nächstgelegene Mälzerei von Berlin aus ist in Lanzberg bei Leipzig. Eine  Brauerei die noch selber mälzt. Und dann wiederum die nächste ist schon Bamberg, also die gesamt Infrastruktur zur Bierproduktion, die es hier mal gab, die existiert schon nicht mehr.
und heißt das, dass auch alle großen Brauereien sich dann aus diesen Mälzereien aus diesen Wenigen  bedienen?
Augustiner gehört zum Beispiel dazu, aus München. Das ja eine von den Selbstbrauereien aus München. Und meiner Meinung nach die Beste.
Und die mälzen tatsächlich in der Münchner Innenstadt. Und das auch noch nach dem Tennenmalzverfahren.
Und heutzutage wird in großen Silos gemälzt, das ist einfach ein riesengroßer Kasten, wo dann nen Rührwerk drin ist, das für das Umrühren sorgt.
Mhmh
Jetzt ist aber das Problem, dadurch dass dann da auch mal 10 12 15 Meter Malz über einander liegen, haben die Keimlinge nicht so viel Platz um sich zu entwickeln.
Und die Augustiner Brauerei ist tatsächlich mal hingegangen, da kam nämlich irgendein Betriebswirtschaftler in den 70er Jahren meinte irgendwie "Ja topp Innenstadtlage hier in München, und wir benutzen die um da 80 cm hoch unser Malz rauszubringen, das ist ganz schön teuer."
Und dann hat er der damalige Inhaber gesagt:" Ok wir machen einen Versuch, wir testen unser Malz gegen ein anderes Malz," haben also genau dasselbe Bier nach genau dem selben Verfahren gebraut. Einmal das klassische Tennenmalz, einmal das moderne Verfahren und das moderne Verfahren ist durchgefallen und ähm...
geschmacklich?
Augustiner geschmacklich ja
Mhmh
Augustiner macht nach wie vor Tennenmalz.
Läuft da wirklich einer mit der Schippe in der Hand oder?...
Die haben sich vor 120 Jahren eine Maschine zum Wenden ihres Malzes gebaut, die sie immer noch einsetzen.
Mh
Und jetzt den Platz dadurch besser auszunutzen, dass man da einfach so Baumkuchen-mäßig mehrere ...
Jaaa...
Holzebenen übereinander oder so?
Ich glaube auch irgendwie heutz zu tage könnte man wahrscheinlich ein Hochhaus dahin stellen, aber die sitzen auch in alten Räumen, also man kann da nicht beliebig nach oben bauen.
Mh...
Ok
Ja und deswegen ist das Augustiner immer noch bisschen leckerer als die anderen Münchner Biere.
Verstehe, Das heißt davon hängt schon viel ab, nicht alles, aber viel?
Das ist wie immer beim Kochen, dass das Endergebnis direkt mit der Qualität der Zutaten zu tun hat.
Ja, verstehe.
mhm also man kann natürlich zwischendrin auch viel falsch machen, so die großen Feinde des Bieres sind Sauerstoff und Gammel.
Und also man möchte immer möglichst ohne Sauerstoff arbeiten und in einer möglichst sauberen Umgebung.
Man würde eigentlich erwarten, also wäre jetzt zumindest meine Erwartung gewesen, ob man das dann so tut ist dann noch mal eine andere Frage.
Das eigentlich so jede größere Brauerei, diese Mälzerei dann auch noch quasi mit dabei hat und die eigenen Rohstoffe erzeugt.
Das war früher so, und tatsächlich wenn man heut zu tage noch so eine Ausbildung macht. Also es gibt ja Brauer als Meisterberuf, dann lernt man nicht Brauer sondern man lernt Brauer und Mälzer.
Früher hieß, gehörte das zusammen, aber in der Praxis ist es so das die allerwenigsten Brauereien heutzutage ihr eigenes Malz machen.
Mhmh,
Weil das zu schwierig war oder ... teuer auch outgesourct...
Es ist teuer aufwendig schwierig und es war offensichtlich billiger das großen Mälzereien zu überlassen.
Und jetzt sind es drei sagtest du in Deutschland?
Nee drei von hier bis zur größten in Deutschland.
Ach so
Es gibt irgendwie so ungefähr noch ein Dutzend.
Ja
Es gibt aber also in der Nvon Berlin gibt es keine mehr, man müsste über 200 Kilometer fahren um die nächste zu finden.
Mh
so im Süden Deutschlands gibt es noch ein paar, im Westen gibt's auch noch ein paar.
Mh ok
Aber die beliefern dafür den Weltmarkt. Also Weyermann-Malz das wird dann auch schonmal in großen Containern nach Südamerika geschickt für die Brauereien da.
Puh, wie heißen die ? Weyermann.
Weyermann
Nie gehört.
Mh
Aber warum auch, nicht?
Ja es...
Aber es steckt wahrscheinlich fast in jeder 2. Bierflasche drin so das Zeug...
Ja ja und auch egal wo man das Bier herkriegt, ob man es aus Neuseeland kriegt oder ob mans aus den USA oder wo auch immer Südamerika...
Echt die shippen das auch international?
Die shippen das international. Es gibt ein paar Konkurrenten in dem Feld, also Carlsen Molting aus Belgien ist so der große Andere.
Mhmh
Und...
Krass
Ja
Das heißt, ... das heißt das die Gerste kommt wahrscheinlich aus Deutschland, wird dann hier irgendwie so ein bisschen gewälzt, keimt ein wenig vor sich hin und wird dann verpackt und auf die andere Seite des Planeten geschickt damit sie da dann zum Bier gebraut wird und das wird dann wieder auf die andere Seite des Planeten geschickt, damits getrunken wird?
Ungefähr so funktioniert das ja.
seufz
Ein großer Wahnsinn
Jaja...
Globalisierung mein Freund.
Jetzt sind wir schon so ein bisschen abgekommen von diesem eigentlichen ...
vom Biermachen, ja wir waren nämlich immer noch beim Mahlen des Malzes ne?
Ja.. Eigentlich waren wir ja noch bei den Sumerern aber...
Ja
Da können wir ja vielleicht nochmal drauf zurückkommen, das wir nicht zu sehr durcheinander kommen.
Also Gerste muss es aber nicht immer sein?
Gerste hat so ein paar Eigenschaften die es besonders günstig machen zum Bierbrauen unter anderem weil relativ viele Enzyme produziert werden beim Mälzen
und aber man kann eigentlich aus allem was Stärke enthält Bier machen.
So ich denke so ein Hefeweizen hat jeder schon mal gehört, da ist wie der Name sagt Weizen drin.
Hmm
Aber so dieses klassische Massenbrauereibier aus den USA genau Core Miller Bud sind die 3 großen. Da ist halt ein erheblicher Maisanteil mit dabei, wodurch das Bier halt nach nichts schmeckt.
Aber schon auch Gerste?
Schon auch Gerste ja, aber irgendwie sogenanntes American Adjuncts Lager ist die Kategorie. Und diese Adjuncts diese Zusätze das ist halt viel Mais, weil Mais in den USA einfach billig zu bekommen ist.
Ja ohne Ende.
Sehr billige Stärkequelle.
Verstehe ok.
Und also bis hin zu exotischen Sachen. Ich hab ein Bier getrunken, das war aus ich glaube Yamwurzeln oder Tapioka gemacht. Also alles was Stärke enthält ist potenziell Quelle eines Bieres.
Hauptsache man kann's ankeimen lassen und es entwickelt dabei dieses Enzym. Ist es denn bei allen Pflanzensorten auch das selbe Enzym oder ist es nur so was ähnliches?
Nee also es... nicht alle Pflanzen lassen sich mälzen. Also wenn ich jetzt eine Kartoffel nehme und da Bier draus machen will ist das ein bisschen schwierig, da muss ich also mit zum Beispiel 30% Gerste arbeiten. Da reichen die Enzyme aus dem Gerstenmalz dann aus um die Stärke aus der Kartoffel auch noch mit abzubauen.
Mhmh
also nicht alle Körner machen das mit dem mit diesen Enzymen oder so das man das technisch verwenden kann. aber man kann sich dann so eine Hälfte Hälfte das mischen und dann geht das schon.
Aber Gerste ist eigentlich the real thing?
Genau
Wobei ich jetzt dem Weizenbier seine Qualität gar nicht absprechen möchte, also mit Weizen geht's auch gut?
Mit Weizen gehts auch gut es geht auch mit diversen anderen. es gibt also ein Weizenvorläufer namens Emmer und in dem einen oder anderen Bioladen in Berlin bekommt man also auch Emmerbier zu kaufen.
Emma?
Emmer E M M E R
Mhmh
Was heißt das ist ein Vorläufer?
Wilder Weizen, also unser moderner Weizen ist ja ganz schön hochgezüchtet.
Ja
Und Emmer ist sozusagen die weit entfernte Vorläufergeneration die noch Wildwuchs dieses...
Leute tun's aber trotzdem, obwohl es technisch ein bisschen aufwendig ist.
Es gibt in Bayern traditionelle Roggenbiere und die Brauerei wie heißen sie...? Störtebecker! Störtebecker, die sich grade übrigens dadurch hervortun, dass sie viele interessante Bier produzieren. Die produzieren auch wieder ein Roggenbier.
Kehren wir mal wieder kurz zurück in deine Küche. Also du hast dir Malz besorgt.
Genau
Gerstenmalz, nehm ich jetzt mal an?
Genau.
Von...? Weidemann?
Es war Weyermann und
Weyermann...
ich hab's online bestellt bei Herrn Herrkoma aus Tetnang hopfenundmehr.de .
aha
Ein eigentlich ganz großartiger Laden, außer dass sie mittlerweile nicht mehr mit DHL liefern sondern mit GLS. Und ich find GLS ganz furchtbar, aber naja.
Ne Mühle hab ich mir auch gleich dazu gekauft und der nächste Schritt ist also das Malz zu nehmen und durch die Mühle durch zu jagen, zu schroten.
Also ich meine in welcher Form kommt denn das? Also wie wenn man jetzt das Malz erhält wie was ist so die Konsistenz.
Du stellst es dir so vor wie ein Sack Getreide, also es lässt sich optisch von Weitem nicht von normalem Getreide unterscheiden. Nur wenn du genauer hinguckst, stellst du fest, dass da so ein bisschen...
Also keimen heißt jetzt nicht, dass da jetzt schon grüne Pflänzchen daraus kommen?
Die kommen daraus die werden wieder also es wird nach dem Keimen gedart. Ist der Fachbegriff in der Dar. Das heißt durch Zuführung von Wärme wird der Kram wieder weggetrocknet und dann wird das nochmal geschüttelt. Und die grünen Keimlinge die lässt man ungefähr soweit rauswachsen wie das Korn groß ist.
Also die Körner sind so 3-4 Milimeter lang.
mhmh
Dann lässt man das 3-4 Millimeter rauswachsen. Dann wird es gedarrt und dann vertrocknet dieser grüne Keimling und fällt auch wieder ab. Also den sieht dann quasi nicht. Das sieht im Wesentlichen erstmal aus wie Getreide.
Mhm
Ok und es ist alles trocken?
Ist trocken ja.
Also die das Ergebnis des Mälzens hängt ein bisschen davon ab bei welchen Temperaturen man das tut und welche Feuchtigkeit man da drin hat. Also ob man sozusagen eher bei 80 Grad und wenig Feuchtigkeit arbeitet oder bei 130 Grad und viel Feuchtigkeit entstehen verschiedene Sorten Malze also die unterscheiden sich.
Es gibt nicht nur das Malz. Ganz früher also wenn man jetzt mal 300 400 Jahre alte Bücher raussucht. Die gibt's ja mittlerweile zum Glück eingescannt bei Google.
Und
Das heißt Weißbier was der Bayer ja eigentlich als Name verwendet für Weizenbier ist eigentlich falsch?
Die immer stattfindet wenn irgendwelche Lebensmittel braun werden. Also ob man sich ein Steak bräht oder ob man sich einen Toast macht oder ob man das Malz bei höheren Temperaturen dart, das ist jeweils der selbe Prozess mit ähnlichen Reaktionen, der zu einer Braunfärbung führt. Und überm Feuer gibt es dann dieses Braunbier.
Es gibt dann noch ein paar Varianten, es gibt so genanntes Melanoidin-Malz. Das wird dann so ein bisschen rötlich das hat dann also was mit dem entsprechenden Austarieren der Feuchtigkeit und der Hitze zu tun.
gemälzt hab ich selber noch nicht irgendwann später vielleicht mal, dann wüsste ich auch die Parameter aus dem Kopf.
Ganz wichtig für den Bierbrauer sind auch noch die sogenannten Karamellmalze. Was da passiert ist das man durch Wahl der entsprechenden Parameter dafür sorgt, dass die Enzyme auch schon so ein bisschen anfangen zu wirken,
Und der trägt zur Vollmundigkeit des Bieres bei, also dann schmeckt es ein bisschen runder und wohlgefälliger und...
mhmh
leckererer.
mh
Ja
Genau ohne Malz geht es schon mal nicht und so der wichtigste Parameter den man findet ist die Helligkeit des Malzes, die bei uns angegeben wird in EBC european blackness wofür auch immer das C steht.
die Amis rechnen in - die haben natürlich wieder ihre eigenen Einheiten - die rechnen in Lavibond.
So findet man auch Umrechnungsfaktoren.
Heutzutage wird tatsächlich größtenteils mit sehr sehr hellen Basismalzen gearbeitet und wenn man dunkleres Bier haben will, dann setzt man sogenanntes Röstmalz dazu.
Also so ein Pilsner-Malz ist das hellste Malz was man bekommen hat, das hat dann ne Farbe von 2-3 EBC.
Ah European Brewery Convention.
Nicht unbedingt jetzt für die, also da gibt es so verschiedene äh
Mh
Ja dann gibt's den EBC Wert für Helligkeit. Alles klar jaja
Genau genau
Was man halt heut zu tage macht, wenn man dunkles Bier produziert ist sowas wie 90 oder 95% eines hellen Malzes zu nehmen und dann noch 5-10 % eines séhr sehr dunklen Malzes, also bis hin zu Malzen, die 1100-1200 EBC haben,
die erst möglich waren zu produzieren seit der Erfindung der Patentdarre.
Die Patentdarre ist also eine Metalltrommel, die von unten erhitzt wird und dadurch dass die Temperaturen so hoch sind würde das Malz anfangen zu brennen und damit es nicht brennt wird es also von oben gelöscht mit so einer Art Sprinkler, das ist die Patentdarre.
mh
Und da wurde festgestellt, dass es halt die Ausbeute nicht so hoch ist. Die Trinker haben sich damals beschwert als die Brauer umgestellt haben vor etwa 200 Jahren von durchgängig etwas dunkleren Malze auf helle Basismalze und ganz dunkle Zusatzmalze, gab es beschwerden, dass das Bier nicht mehr schmeckt wie früher, aber das hat die Brauer nicht interessiert.
Gut, das heißt du hast dir jetzt also das Malz gekauft und das war jetzt erstmal so normales Gerstenmalz, nehm ich jetzt mal an und ... das ist jetzt auch noch nicht irgend ne... also Standard?
Ja luftgetrocknet ist out heut zu tage, das macht man nicht mehr.
mh
Genau genau
Ok...
Wieviel muss man da jeztt so kaufen bis man da irgendwie jetzt in der Küche loslegen kann?
Also man kann rechnen, dass wenn man 20 Liter Bier macht, was so eine Größenordnung ist, die für einen Anfänger empfehlenswert ist, weil einen 20 Liter Topf den kriegt man immernoch selber hoch gehoben. Da muss man sich nicht vorher Gedanken drüber machen, dass man einen Prozessschritt vergessen hat, wo einem jetzt plötzlich die Pumpe fehlt oder sowas.
Ja. Stimmt.
Also 4 Kilo Malz 20 Liter Bier kann man rechnen.
4 Kilo Malz
mh
20 Liter... ok
Da darf man aber am Anfang gar nicht so sehr drüber nachdenken. Das spielt eine Rolle wenn man das Malz Tonnenweise kauft, weil dann ist es finanzieller Unterschied, weil so für nen Hobbybrauer so die 50Cent mehr sollte man sich erstmal keine Gedanken drüber machen.
Mhm
Aber wenn ich mich jetzt nicht verrechnet habe, dann ungefähr so 200 Gramm von diesem Malz geht in so eine Flasche rein?
Öhmmmm 20 Liter 4 Kilo also 2Liter 400 Gramm also 1 Liter 200 Gramm 100 Gramm pro Flasche 200 Gramm pro Liter.
Achso ja die Flasche ist ja nur ein...
Halber Liter
halber Liter ok gut. ja
genau genau und diese hier ist sogar nur ein drittel Liter.
Ja hier steht eine aber da reden wir jetzt noch nicht drüber.
Der nächste Prozessschritt, also gemahlen haben wir es jetzt, geschrotet.
Haben wir das schon?
Haben wir schon , ne haben wir noch nicht, aber ich hab mehrfach versucht darüber zu erzählen, da ist jetzt mahlen dran.
Ja genau
Und diese gusseiserne Mühle wurde also seit den 20er Jahren unverändert produziert, bis vor ungefähr 5 Jahren als die Firma Pleite gemacht hat.
mh
... ist jetzt nicht das allerbeste Profi-Equipment. Also für seine 4 Kilo Malz muss man dann 20 Minuten kurbeln in etwa bis man die geschrotet hat. Einfach wie so ein Fleischwolf sieht e svorne aus, also so ein Trichter, so ne Schnecke un dhinten sind einfach 2 Scheiben die sich aufeinander drehen deren Abstand man einstellen kann.
mhm
Also jetzt die unmittelbare Außenhaut des Malzes so wenn man es erhält das soll beim Aufbrechen gleich bleiben.
Genau was dir beim Vollkornbrot immer zwischen den Zähnen stecken bleibt.
Ahja
Das sind die Spelzen.
Ok
Und...
Die braucht man später noch.
Ja
Also man macht da so eine Art Getreidebrei draus.
und der ganze Trick bei diesem Meischen ist die richtigen Temperaturen zu erwischen, damit die Enzyme anfangen, ihre Arbeit zu tun und die Stärke in Zucker umwandeln.
Was könnte das für eine Temperatur sein?
Das sind es gibt 2 also diese Amylasen die die Stärken zu Zucker umsetzen da gibt es 2 von die Alpha-Amylase und die Beta-Amylase und die haben unterschiedliche optimale Temperaturen. Nämlich die eine bei 62 Grad die Beta-Amylase die vergärbaren Zucker produziert, also wo dann hinterher auch Alkohol draus wird.
Und die Alpha-Amylase bei 72 Grad, die unvergärbaren Zucker herstellt, also wo nicht nur aber auch wo dann irgendwie Zucker übrig bleibt den die Hefe nicht mehr verspeist bekommt,
ja in the long run wird aus dem Zucker Alkohol
Mhmh
ist heutzutage nicht mehr notwendig, weil die Malze...
Eiweißraste?
Wenn man nen Roggen-Bier macht braucht man noch eine Gummi-Rast um irgendwie diese diese gallerartigen Substanzen abzubauen.
mhmh
Wenn man ein Hefeweizen macht, gibt es noch die Ferulasäure-Rast wo die Ferulasäure gebildet wird, die ein Vorläufer ist von Nelkenaroma Vanillearoma und ähnlichen Substanzen und weiß nicht ob es dir aufgefallen ist, wenn man mal so ein Weizenbier trinkt, die schmecken manchmal so ein bisschen nelkig.
So gewürzig scharf.
mh
Ich überleg grad mal.
... nelkig...
Also nicht alle aber so einige wo man
mh
so ein Gewürzcharakter..
Also ich bin auch wirklich ein schlechter Schmecker von daher bin ich überhaupt nicht ...
Na wenn man es einmal gesagt kriegt schmeckt man es immer wieder heraus, das ist das Faszinierende.
Ja das kann gut sein, aber ich glaub dann auch immer alles.
Naja ok zu unseren Temperaturrasten,... das ist übrigens auch noch eine spannende Geschichte.
nur in ne kleinere körnung zu bringen, damit das überhaupt erstmal erreicht werden kann und man macht das im Idealfall so, dass diese Außenhülle mehr oder weniger intakt bleibt.
Das heißt, man drückt es eigentlich nur so ein bisschen an dass es so innen so ein bisschen zerschrotet also wie es wahrscheinlich auch bei so einer kleineren Nuss wäre wenn man die halt nicht ganz drückt, die sind also... Haselnüsse zum Beispiel, außen so ein bisschen weicher noch so und dann bleibt die quasi die Schale erhalten, aber drin ist es alles so ein bisschen zerstört?
Genau
Und das tut man in so einen großen Topf?
Und da gibt man dann Wasser dazu?
Genau
Und sonst nichts?
Sonst nichts. Das erhitzt man dann auf die richtigen Temperaturen und..
muss dann eine Pause also ne Rast machen zu bestimmten Sachen je nachdem was man da jetzt reingeschmissen hat, was man erzielen will und welchen Anteil von Alpha und Betaamylase man gerne so wirken hätte?
genau genau genau
Und das heißt man hat da irgendwie so eine Temperaturfühler drin.
mhmm
und muss dann immer so gucken obs jetzt die Temperatur auch hat und wenn man die halten will entsprechend das Feuer runterdrehen.
Genau genau, weil in der Regel bei den Mengen mit denen man da arbeitet man das Feuer auch ausmachen kann. Alle 20 Minuten mal gucken ob man kurz nachheizen muss, also so ein großer Topf mit 20 Liter Wasser ist erstaunlich Temperaturstabil, da muss man nicht viel tun.
Das heißt man feuert immer nur mal wieder an, wenn man dann quasi auf die nächste Temperaturstufe gehen möchte?
Genau üblicherweise.
Beziehungsweise, das was ich da grade beschreibe ist ein sogenanntes Infusionsverfahren. So macht man Bier heutzutage, außer da, wo Bier noch traditionell hergestellt wurde, da wird das sogenannte Dekoktionsverfahren verwendet.
Und der Grund ist ein ganz einfacher: so Bier wird schon seit 4000 Jahren gemacht. Die Erfindung des  Thermometers liegt allerdings erst 200 Jahre zurück. 250...
Das war dieser ... wer war schuld? Fahrenheit Celsius? Irgendeiner von diesen Jungs hat das Thermometer erfunden.
Ja
Und da fragt man sich natürlich: "Wie haben die das mit den Temperaturen vorher gemacht?"
Ja?
Finger reingehalten wahrscheinlich.
das ist nicht genau genug.
Und man kommt nicht sofort drauf aber der Trick ist relativ gut. Was konnte man denn auch schon vor 700 Jahren messen? Volumen konnte man messen, also wenn man seinen Standardeimer hatte, und wusste irgendwie so ein großer Bottich da passen 100 Eimer rein.
Kann ich 20 Eimer rausnehmen, kann die in den Kessel tun, kann das zum Kochen bringen nahezu 100 Grad und dann schütt ich es wieder zurück und dann stellt sich eine Mischtemperatur ein und die kann man relativ genau kontrollieren.
Mh
Und das wurde da tatsächlich gemacht. Also da gab es einen sogenannten Meischebottich, das war tatsächlihc ein Holzbottich großer und daneben die Meischepfanne, das ist so ein Kessel
und wenn man mal so ein Brauerlogo sieht, da gibt es diverse Brauutensilien, eins davon ist ein langer Stiel mit einem Eimer dran.
Und dann wurde halt umgeschöpft mit dem langen Stiel mit dem Eimer aus dem einen in das andere rüber
Und dann wurde wieder rübergeschöpft die nächste Temperatur angefahren und so weiter und so fort.
Mh
Hat also wenn man das tut also erstens ist es sauviel Arbeit. Man muss rumkleckern und umschöpfen, deswegen ist es so ein bisschen unbeliebt bei Brauern heut zu tage. Also bei den modernene etwas Fauleren.
traditionell wird noch viel Bier gemacht in Deutschland so.
Hat den Effekt das beim Kochen sich geschmacklich sich auch Dinge verändern. Zum einen wird die Stärke besser aufgeschlossen, man erhöht die Ausbeute.
Und zum Anderen kriegt man so einen bestimmten.... schwer zu definierenden kernigen Geschmack, also das Bier schmeckt runder voller angenehmer, wenn man das Dekoktion macht.
Wenn man die alte Methode...
mit der alten Methode jaja.
So also man kann ähnliche Effekte erzielen, wenn man bisschen rumtrickst und die schon erwähnten Karamellmalze und die Melanoidinmalze und dann mit dem richtigen Dosierungen....
Man kann aber nen die Dekoktion geschmacklich nicht ersetzen.
So man kann andere Dinge tun damit auch ein rundes Bier rauskommt, aber das ist dann was anderes.
Ok das heißt das ist eigentlich so die hohe Kunst.
Genau
Aber viel mehr Aufwand.
Viel mehr Aufwand. Auf jeden Fall, so. Also muss man dann halt von Hand schöpfen bzw. sich eine Pumpe anschaffen, die Meische pumpen kann also Getreidebrei, was teuer und aufwendig ist.
Es ist unser erstes Bier.
Genau
Und die amerikanischen Hombrewer haben natürlich irgendwie selbst das einfache Verfahren noch optimiert.
Da machen sie sogenannte Single Step Infusion Mashing und zwar haben sie gesagt: "Naja so zwischen 62 und 72 Grad da liegen ja noch jede Menge andere Temperaturen.""
Und machen dann sowas wie einfach bei 69 Grad den Kram eine Stunde rumstehen lassen und das dann als fertig deklarieren.
Verstehe.
Ja, was im Übrigen auch wunderbar funktioniert, also es müssen keine schlechten Biere dabei rauskokmmen.
Und also insbesondere ein Hefeweizen das geschmacklich sehr sehr von der richtigen Hefe lebt, kann man das bedenkenlos machen.
Mhmh
Und so bei dem Infusion Mashing da heizt man sein Wasser auf 72 Grad auf
Und dann wenn man das Getreide reinschüttet kühlt es sich ein bisschen ab auf 69. Dann macht man den Deckel drauf, macht eine Stunde was anderes zum Beispiel Flaschen waschen.
Aber was hast du denn jetzt für Schritte jetzt gemacht? Also du hast natürlich jetzt schon mehrere Varianten gebraut, aber so wenn man jetzt so bei deinem ersten Bier sind oder sagen wir mal bei jedermanns potenziellen ersten Bier.
Hast du jetzt schon solche Rastpunkte gemacht, das heißt du hast erstmal ne gewisse Temperatur erreicht und das dann da einfach stehen lassen.
Genau und für das erste Bier würd ich sogar sagen, lässt man das mit den mehreren Rasttemperaturen weg und macht so eine Kombirast nennt man das auf deutsch.
mhmh
Und auf englisch single step infusion mashing.
Ja
Also das ist tatsächlich das was man tut. Man nimmt einen Topf Wasser mit wenn man 20 Liter Bier will vielleicht 15 Liter.
erhitzt die auf 72 Grad, schüttet sein Getreide dazu, macht einen Deckel drauf und wartet 1 1/2 Stunden.
Und man will aber irgendwann rauskriegen ob man jetzt fertig ist, ob man lang genug gewartet hat.
Ja
Und das ist die Stelle wo das Jod ins Spiel kommt. Die Jodprobe
Also welcher Prozess findet denn jetzt eigentlich tatsächlich statt? Also...
So chemisch gesehen?
Ja weil die Mälzerei ist ja schon durch, das heißt da ist schon das...
Das Enzym drin.
Das Enzym ist irgendwie drin und das wird jetzt eigentlich aktiviert.
Zuckerbrühe machen.
So Und wie misst man den Zicker den Zucker?
Genau
Mit einem Refraktometer.
Nee also man kann natürlich kosten, dann schmeckt man dass es süß ist,
Ja.
das kann man auch mal machen.
Den genauen Zuckergehalt bestimmt man natürlich streng wissenschaftlich mit einer Bierspindel oder einem Refraktometer.
Soso
Genau, so und damit wir hier nicht die ganze Zeit über Zuckerbrühe reden müssen, die Fachterminologie der Fachbegriff für Zuckerbrühe ist "Würze".
Also was der Brauer macht ist Würze herstellen.
Aus Meische.
aus Malz.
Ja Malz wird zu Meische und aus dem wird die Würze.
Da sind wir aber noch nicht, denn wir müssen noch die Jodprobe machen, um zu gucken ob wir mit dem meischen fertig sind.
Mhmh
Jod kann man ja zum Stärkenachweis benutzen. So wie gesagt Schulunterricht. Der eine oder andere erinnert sich vielleicht ganz düster.
reagiert schwarz so dunkelblau lila schwarz mit Stärke und dieses Jod ist eigentlich so eine bräunliche Geschichte.
Das heißt man nimmt einen weißen Teller. Macht ein bisschen was aus seiner Meische auf seinen Teller drauf. Macht dann so einen Tropfen Brauerjod obendrauf und wenn es braun bleibt dann ist es fertig und wenn es schwarz wird dann ist es noch nicht fertig und man muss es noch ein bisschen stehen lassen.
Mh
Ah verstehe.
Genau Farbindikator. Es ist übrigens tatsächlich. Es gibt einen ganz tollen Film, über wie bei Warsteiner Bier hergestellt wird. Also wie mal so eine moderne Bierfabrik aussieht, ja?
Alles andere ist automatisiert.
Mhmh
Gut, das heißt wenn es braun bleibt, dann hat es den richtigen...
Genau dann ist da keine Stärke mehr, dann ist die Stärke zu Zucker umgesetzt.
Also es bleibt auch nichts übrig von der Stärke?
Und wenn all das, was auslaugbar ist, umgesetzt ist, dann ist die Jodprobe auch negativ, dann kann man weitermachen.
Aber es bleibt schon noch was zurück. Also die der Rest der da übrig bleibt der sogenannte Treber
Die festen Bestandteile, wenn alles rausgelöst ist.
ist ganz hervorragendes Tierfutter, weil sehr eiweißhaltig, sehr mineralhaltig, sehr hochwertig.
Mhmh
Ballaststoffe drin durch die Spelzen.
man kann auch Treberbrot draus backen, was mir persönlich nicht so zusagt, weil auch wieder die Spelzen drin landen, dann hat man diesen "Bleibtindenzähnenstecken"Effekt.
Du hast ja vorhin gesagt es sei ja total wichtig, dass diese Spelzen, dass das irgendwie erhalten bleibt, warum ist das denn so wichtig?
Fürs Läutern, weil das ist jetzt auch der nächste Prozessschritt zu dem wir kommen.
Ok, also wir haben jetzt sozusagen die Würze?
mhm
Die im Wesentlichen eigentlich Zucker, also Stärke umgewandelt zu Zucker durch diese Enzyme ist.
Teilweise Zucker der später zu Alkohol werden kann, teilweise nicht.
mhnm
Sonst noch irgendwelche nennenswerten Produktionen aus diesem ...?
Mnjo das ist so das Wichtigste, alles andere kann man erstmal ignorieren.
Und was ist so die Konsistenz davon so?
Na es ist halt immernoch relativ dünner Getreidebrei, weil man hat noch die festen Brocken drin, es ist halt noch nicht Würze es ist noch Meische. Es also ...
Ok
Also je nachdem was man für ein Bier macht, wenn man so einen Doppelbock macht, dann ist es auch tatsächlich Getreidebrei Getreidebrei.
Ansonsten hat man halt so 2 Drittel Flüssigkeit obendrauf und so ein Drittel Körnerbrei Matsch untendrin.
Ok
Und den will man jetzt loswerden. Also man will aus der Meische die Würze extrahieren.
Mhmh
Und das macht man indem man es läutert.
Läutern heißt im Wesentlichen durch ein Sieb kippen
Allerdings ist es gar nicht so einfach, weil dieses Sieb, wenn es zu engmaschig ist dann setzt es sich zu und wenn es zu weitmaschig ist dann rasseln die Körner durch und kommen unten an.
Und die Spelzen sind deswegen wichtig, wei lwenn man hier einen Topf nimmt wo man unten ein Lochblech drin hat, mit nicht zu großen Löchern, vielleicht so 1,5 mm oder noch besser Schlitze von 1,5 Millimeter Breite.
Dann kann da die Flüssigkeit abfließen und dann fällt auch manchmal noch so ein Korn durch.
Allerdings nur am Anfang, weil die Spelzen anfangen sich in einander zu verkeilen dadrüber und so eine Art natürliches Filterbett bauen.
Ah verstehe
Wo die Flüssigkeit zwischendurch fließen kann, aber die Spelzen halten dann die festen Bestandteile davon ab durchzurutschen.
Das heißt man gibt das alles in den Topf.
Als hätte man so ein Haufen Muschelschalen, die dann...
Genau genau genau
mh
Und ja das heißt man gießt das in einen entsprechenden Läuterbottich. Der über einen doppelten Boden verfügt mit den Schlitzen drin und lässt dann erstmal ein bisschen ab.
Also am Anfang kommt dann noch so ein bisschen trüber Kram durch, bis es sich das sozusagen soweit abgesetzt hat, dass diese Filterwirkung auch eintritt, dass heißt erstmal nimmt man das unten raus und schüttet es oben wieder rein.
Ja
Und irgendwann fängts an klar zu laufen und dann lässt man ... dreht man auf und dann kommt da die blanke Würze raus.
... als nächstes gibt man dann noch einen Nachguss drauf. Das heißt man macht nochmal Wasser warm und gibt das nochmal oben auf diesen Treber drauf um sozusagen den Rest auch auszuspülen, damit der ganz Zucker der da noch dran klebt auch durchgespült wird.
Mhmh
Und jetzt sieht das auch schon ein bisschen aus wie Bier?
Es sieht farblich entfernt wie Bier aus. Ja, also noch ein bisschen trübe in der Regel ist nicht ganz so klar wie jetzt das Bier das man kennt. Was aber auch gefiltert ist.
Aber im Prinzip sieht es schon aus wie... es schäumt natürlich nicht, es ist kein CO2 drin und es ist auch warm. Es ist also warme Zuckerbrühe die ungefähr entfernt wie Bier aussieht, ja.
mhmh
Das ist die Würze?
das ist die Würze.
Nach dem Läutern?
Nach dem Läutern.
Ok
Ja, und der nächste wichtige Prozessschritt...
Was hast du denn da als Sieb genommen?
Ich habe tatsächlich mir ein Läuterblech genommen. Es gibt total großartige 70er Jahre Ende der 70er frühe 80er gabs die Hobbythek mit Jean Pütz.
Mhmh
Und Jean Pütz hat auch mal Bier gebraut und hat sich also heldenhaft darum verdient gemacht, dass das Bierbrauen in Haushalten legal geworden ist. Das war es nämlich damals noch nicht.
Also er hat tatsächlich angefangen Verhandlungen mit dem Zoll aufzunehmen.
Also selbst der Verkauf von Bierbrauzutaten war verboten.
Ach
In den 80ern.
Und er hat da also.
Ja er hat da eine Ausnahmegenehmigung erwirkt für irgendwie seine Hobbytheklieferung und seit dem ist das alles ein bisschen liberaler geworden.
Ah aber warum war denn das verboten?
mh naja Bier unterliegt der Biersteuer und du weißt wie so Bürokratien sind, wenn die Möglichkeit besteht ihn oh das können wir gleich noch ausführen, aber erstmal machen wir noch das Bier fertig.
Ja ok
Bevor es bizarr wird
gut gut gut gut
Naja und der hat also da vorgeschlagen, man könne doch ein einen Stuhl nehmen und umdrehen, sodass die vier Stuhlbeine nach oben hängen und dann einen Topf in die Mitte stellen und dann eine Stoffwindel nehmen und mit Wäscheklammern an den vier Stuhlbeinen befestigen und damit läutern.
Und das geht ungefähr so gut wie es klingt.
Also meine Empfehlung wäre, wenn man für irgendwas Geld ausgibt, ja also wenn man einen großen Topf hat oder so einen Einkocher von Omas Boden, dann kann man damit schon arbeiten.
Und das aller aller aller aller erste Investment, was man tätigen sollte. Ist eine ordentlich Lösung zum Läutern.
ein gelasertes Blech mit Schlitzen drin, das genau da unten reinpasst. Das also sozusagen aufliegt, das sieht dann so ähnlich aus wie eine professionelle Läuterlösung.
Also in den großen Brauereien gibt es diese sogenannten Senkböden, die in der Regel aus Messing waren mit großen Schlitzen drin, Im Prinzip das miniaturisiert.
mhmh
Was ich mir zugelegt hatte, eigentlich wollte ich mir eine andere Lösung bauen.
Und hab aber auf Ebay so ein Starterset geschossen für wenig Geld und da war dieses Läuterblech dabei und ich bin schwer begeistert.
Also das funktioniert richtig gut.
Aber es ist einfahc nur so ein geknicktes Blech mit Schlitzen drin, was man in den Topf in den Eimer unten reinlegt und da genau reinpasst und
durch den Knick hat man quasi noc hso einen Bereich wo es dann eben vorne aus dem Hahn noch rauslaufen kann.
genau
so funktioniert das.
mhmh
Jo und dann schüttet man das alles in einen Eimer. Wartet ein bisschen, sogenannte Läuterruhe damit sich das absenkt.
Dann wie gesagt ein paar Liter durchlaufen lassen und umschütten.
So vielleicht 21 22 bisschen was hat man Kochverlust.
mhmh
Matschepampe
Genau. so
Kann man aber an sein Hausschwein verfüttern.
Kann man ans Hausschwein versch.. verfüttern, da hat man dann hinterher tollen Schinken zu seinem Bier.
Essen´Hunde das auch? Nee ne?
Dann schon lieber ins Hausschwein stecken.
Genau
20 Liter im dicken Eimer.
mhm
Und das liegt jetzt so vor sich hin.
So und das ist jetzt quasi das ... woraus man das Bier macht?
Und der kommt dann zum sogenannten Hopfenkochen dazu.
Nimmt man nochmal den Topf mit seiner Würze und bringt den zum Kochen und lässt den vor sich hinkochen so 1,5 Stunden und ...
Hopfen kommt jetzt in welcher Form? Also wir reden jetzt nur von den Blüten oder?
Das sind die Hopfenblüten also Hopfen ist eine Pflanze aus der Familie der Hanfgewächse.
man hat es manchmal wenn man so einen ich finds bei Jever relativ deutlich. Wenn man so ein Jever aufmacht riecht so ein bisschen nach Gras.
Und die Pflanze ist auch eng verwandt, also die spannenden Sachen die man will, die leben auch in kleinen gelben Harzdrüsen auf der Oberfläche der weiblichen Blüten der Pflanze.
Und also die Analogien gehen weiter, man kriegt nämlich Doldenhopfen, was einfach die geernteten Blüten sind, so wie Gras.
Ja
dann gibt es sogenannte Hopfenpallets, das sind dann also ausgeschlagen durchgesiebte gepresste Dinger, also wie man sich das mit Haschisch vorstellt ja, also..
kleine grüne gepresste Dinge.
Und dann gibt's Hopfenöl
das also extrahiert wird.
Ja riecht ähnlich funktioniert ähnlich ist eine ähnliche Pflanze, nur nicht ganz so verboten.
Funktioniert ähnlich?
Ja
mh
Ja macht auch müde, also
Wenn man mal wieder so richtig schön müde werden möchte, ...
Ja Hopfentee, tatsächlich Hopfentee funktioniert muss man nicht mal ein Bier dafür trinken.
Ja und das kommt dann da rein und da unterscheidet man noch also je nachdem ob man den Hopfen am Anfang reingibt.
Dann spielt der eher ne Rolle wie bitter das Bier wird, wenn man den am Ende reingibt, also kurz vor Kochende, dann gehts eher darum wie das Bier schmeckt.
Also dann gehts ums Aroma, man redet dann von Bitterhopfen und Aromahopfen, obwohl also trennscharf ist die Unterscheidung nicht.
Also man auch mit Aromahopfen für Bittere sorgen und umgekehrt.
Aber genau
Wo kriegt man jetzt den Hopfen her?
in Tetnang Teknang.
Aber ich meine wo holen die Brauereien das her, so im großen Maßstab?
Das allerdings nicht die einzige Hopfenanbauregion weltweit, es gibt in Amerika gibt's Hopfen in England gibt's Hopfen in Neuseeland gibt's Hopfen und auch da eine große Vielfalt.
Aber Deutschland ist schon ganz weit vorn?
Also so mit der Traditionspflege ist das manchmal so ein Problem.
Ok als beim Hopfen wird gewartet bis dann die Blüten raus sind, dann werden die abgeschnitten und dann werden die noch zerbröselt zerkleinert oder kriegt man die jetzt so in diesen kompletten...?
Es kommt drauf an manchmal gibt es das als Doldenhopfen, das sind die kompletten Blüten am Stück.
Ja
Manchmal wirds halt noch zerkleinert und zu Pallets gepresst, so Haschischstyle.
Ja und in welcher Form hast du es jetzt genommen?
Ich hab also für Anfänger ist es besser mit den Palletts anzufangen mit den Hopfenpallets, aus dem Grund weil es weniger Sauerei ergibt.
So die da bleibt dann halt so ein pulvriger Rest übrig, der auch durch die Schläuche durchgeht und sobald man irgendwas macht mit umfüllen abpumpen und so weiter und so fort. Man hat Doldenhopfen dann verstopfen die Schläuche, das ist ein ganz elender Stress. also ....
mh
... Doldenhopfen ist natürlich qualitativ hochwertiger, weil beim Pressen der Palletts diese Harzdrüsen aufplatzen dann anfangen zu oxidieren.
Und die ... Dolden sind in der Regel frischer und qualitativ hochwertiger. Sind aber auch wesentlich größer und ein wesentlich größerer Stress zu verarbeiten.
mhmh
Ja was auch nicht in den Pumpen hängenbleibt und Filtern.
Ja
der ganze Ärger mit Verstopfungm hat man nicht.
Aber
Der wird das jetzt einfach nur dazugegeben und dann schmeckts anders oder was ist jetzt der Grund warum da auch Hopfen mit drin ist?
die waren ja ganz glücklich mit ihrem Getreidebrei.
Die waren ganz glücklich mit ihrem Getreidebrei, aber die hatten da noch kein Hopfen drin.
So üblich war es aber da bestimmte Kräuter tatsächlich auch mitzukochen irgendwann.
und ....
Einfach um dem ganzen andern Geschmack zu geben?
Um dem bisschen Geschmack zu geben um es haltbarer zu machen um dafür zu sorgen, dass es ein bisschen besser kickt.
so die Bier mit Hopfen zu machen ist noch gar nicht so lange üblich. Das wurde 750 rum erfunden in Benediktinerklöstern, hat aber erst so 12. 13. Jahrhundert wirklich Verbreitung gefunden und zwar weil: die Katholische Kirche zu dem Zeitpunkt das Monopol auf diese Kräutermischung hatte mit der man das Bier herstellte. Sogenannte Grut.
Also ich der ein oder andere kennt vielleicht den Wissenschaftsverlag der Gruter, der Name leitet sich von Grut ab.
Und auch das Wort Kräuter hat halt mit Grut zu tun, das etymologisch alles sehr verwandt und
Wie schreibst du das?
G R U T
Ah
Grut
und im Wesentlichen sind da 2 Kräuter drin die heutzutage fast unbekannt bzw. schon fast ausgestorben sind, nämlich Porst und Gagel.
Ja
Diesen Zutaten wurde nachgesagt, dass sie eine leicht psychedelische Wirkung haben.
Und also dieser typische germanische Berserker wird ganz gerne in der Literatur mal auf die Zusätze die sonst im Bier waren unter anderem das Grut zurückgeführt.
mh
Ich weiß auch nicht ob der Selbstversuch so einfach ist, weil also mindestens eins der beiden Kräuter steht auf der roten Liste und man findet es nur in Hochmooren und total selten.
Aber das ist jetzt schon so ein europäisches Ding?
Das ist ... ja nachweisbar in den Bronzezeitkulturen in Europa, also da gibt's durchaus 3 4000 Jahre alte Funde, wo diese Kräuter nachweisbar sind im Bier.
mhmh
Also die Biersteuer wurde so erhoben. und
Ah
Die sind nämlich einfach drauf gekommen, dass durch die Hopfenzugabe das Bier so haltbar wird, das man es über größere Entfernungen transportieren und verkaufen kann.
Die haben dann also angefangen entlang der Handelswege ihr Hopfenbier zu verkaufen und sich damit in direkte Konkurenz zu den Grutbieren zu begeben.
Als die Fürsten gesagt haben: " ok jetzt bloß noch Hopfenbier" war das sozusagen ein Zuschlag an die aufstrebende Hanse, an das Bürgertum an den Handel der stattgefunden und so der lange Stinkefinger an die katholische Kirche.
mh
Ist nicht nach Reinheitsgebot. genau genau
Tun natürlich trotzdem Leute.
Also Hopfen macht das Bier nicht nur das es ihm Geschmack gibt, sondern es macht es auch haltbarer?
Genau
Was wird denn da gehemmt, dass es diese Haltbarkeit oder was macht überhaupt die Haltbarkeit des Bieres aus? Oder was macht die Nichthaltbarkeit des Bieres aus?
die Nichthaltbarkeit des Bieres ist wir hatten es ja vorhin von vergärbarenen und nichvergärbarenen Zuckern.
Genau genau und da wird das Bier entweder sauer oder kriegt einen Pelz und generell nicht so lecker.
Aber das sind doch nur diese Zucker von diesem Alphaamysolenzym?
Das würde tatsächlich das Bier ein bisschen haltbarer machen, man hat aber auch noch Eiweiße drin und alles Mögliche, also das macht das nicht perfekt, allerdings schmeckt das Bier dann auch leer und ohne Körper. Also das ist ...
Ok
Wie gesagt was ich vorhin meinte, wenn man sich seinen Wodka mit Wasser verdünnt, so schmeckt das dann.
Ja
Cores Miller light Budweiser,...
So das ist sozusagen wirkt direkt antibakteriell.
Verstehe. mh
Jo
So und du hast jetzt den Hopfen genommen so im Block, wie hieß das nochmal? Nicht im Block sondern?
Pallets
Pallett genau
mhmh
das heißt das muss man sich wirklich vorstellen wie so ein Stück Haschisch.
Ja na kleinere Klumpen, also es sind so ungefähr Bleistiftdicke Abschnitte die jeweils so einen halben bis einen Zentimeter lang sind,
Aber so ähnliche Konsistenz?
Ähnliche Konsistenz, also ein Vakuumbeutel den schneidet man auf und dann schüttet man das da rein.
ok, hackt das irgendwie klein ? also es ist klebrig oder...
Muss man nicht, das zerfällt von selber.
Ok ist nicht....
Also es ist nicht so stark gepresst, sondern einfach durch das Wasser und die Wärme...
Ok und dann kommt das rein in die Würze, die wir ja jetzt gewonnen haben, dadurch das wir alles schön abgesiebt haben?
Genau genau dann wird es vor sich hingekocht und beim Kochen wird die Alphasäure isomerisiert. Also tatsächlich in den Zustand verwandelt in dem auch bitter ist und antibakteriell.
isomerisiert?
Genau
Was ist das für ein Vorgang?
Das ist ein chemischer Vorgang, wo sozusagen die Vorläufersubstanzen in die richtige Form umgewandelt werden. So das die Moleküle auch alle gleich aussehen...
Ok also erst durch das Erhitzen wird dieser Hopfen überhaupt erst aktiv in dieser gewünschten Form?
Genau
Und die Würze selber vermengt sich jetzt mit diesem Hopfen, wird haltbarer, schmeckt anders und ... wie lange muss man das jetzt noch erhitzen? Also was sind das jetzt für Prozesse?
Das dauert so eine stunde bis ein einhalb, da passieren noch andere Dinge, da werden...
so ist das wieder so auf eine Temperatur bringen und stehen lassen?
Na die Temperatur in dem Fall ist wallend kochen.
Ah ok.
Tatsächlich irgendwie 1,5 Stunden lang ...
Bisher war also alles nur Spaß und jetzt hat man alles beisammen und jetzt gibt man ihm so richtig...
Jetzt gibt man richtig Dampf.
mhm
Dabei werden auch andere Vorläuferstoffe von unangenehmen Substanzen ausgetrieben, also DMS ist so eine Substanz die ... ich glaube Dimetylsulphat aber nagel mich nicht drauf fest.
Wenn das Bier hinterher nach Gemüse schmeckt, dann wurde das nicht ausreichend sorgfältig ausgetrieben beim Kochen.
ja
Und dadurch dass man die Würze nochmal kocht wird sie auch steril gemacht also da kann dann nichts meh ranbrennen.
Ahja, ... so ne stunde kochen heißt aber dass man noch eine ganze Menge Flüssigkeitsverlust hat oder lässt man da den Deckel drauf?
Nee man kocht offen, damit es DMS auch ordentlich abdampfen kann.
Ja
Also so in moderneren Brauereien tut man das teilweise unter Unterdruck, der ist dann sozusagen nicht offen sondern geschlossener Kessel mit reduziertem Druck, der dann abgedampft wird, weil man dann auch weniger Energie braucht.
Für den Hobbybrauer ist es erstmal Deckel runter, kochen lassen alles schön verdampfen lassen.
Also Unterdruck im Gebäude oder was? Also in diesem Raum wo gekocht wird?
Nee der Kessel selber hat dann Unterdruck.
ah
Ja und was beim Kochen allerdings noch passiert ist das eine ganze Menge flüssiger gelöster Eiweiße aus dem Weizen und der Gerste also aus dem Getreide anfängt auszuflocken. So ... gibt dann so bräunliche Flocken, hat so ein bisschen so eine Tofukonsistenz, ist im Wesentlichen auch dasselbe.
Und jetzt hat man also da diese Brühe nach 1,5 Stunden dann endlich kochen fertig mit kochen.
Und bevor es endlich ins Gärfass kann muss der sogenannte Heißtrup, dass ist das also diese ausgeflockten Eiweiße, die Reste vom Hopfen abgetrennt werden.
Das kennt man vielleicht wenn man eine Teetasse hat, ja und also so ein Glas wo man es gut sieht. und umrührt, dann sammeln sich also bildet sich in der Mitte ein Strudel und was man noch so an festen Bestandteilen hat, so kleine Teekrümel Zuckerkrümmel die sammeln sich unten in der Mitte aufm Boden.
mhmh
Und diesen Whirlpooleffekt kann man auch ausnutzen beim Bieren, das heißt wenn man dann fertig ist mit Kochen, ausgeschaltet hat, macht man erstmal einen Deckel drauf, lässt es 10 Minuten zur Ruhe kommen, auch damit die Konvektion (???) aufhört.
Und dann nimmt man sein großes Braupaddel, rührt richtig schön schnell drin um, dass man einen großen Strudel hat.
dann bilden die ganzen festen Bestandteile einen sogenannten Trupkegel unten in der Mitte des Gefäßes und der Rest ist dann relativ blanke Würze.
Und die muss dann eigentlich bloß noch ins Gärbehältnis.
hat den Vorteil, dass durch die heiße Würze, wenn man die direkt ins Gärgefäß gibt auch gleich das Gärgefäß desinfiziert wird.
Hat den Nachteil, dass man über Nacht warten muss bis man die Hefe dazu tun kann, und das natürlich Möglichkeiten gibt für andere fiese Organismen an der Würze rumzuknabbern und sie zu infizieren und schlecht zu machen.
Und die kochende Würze also direkt abkühlt auf ´Zimmertemperatur oder drunter.
mhmh
und in den Gärbehälter tut.
und wie verhindert man das jetzt diese Restbestandteile, die sich da in der Mitte gesammelt haben da ... mit ziehen?
Indem man vorsichtig ist beim Abschlauchen. also.
Die bleiben da wirklich so definiert da so in der Mitte kleben?
Die sind so ein bisschen klibbrig und bleiben nicht besonders definiert kleben, aber gut genug.
die Alternative ist filtern.
ja
gibt so...
Wollte grad fragen müsste auch gehen oder?
Also man hat bei dem ganzen Prozess relativ viel Möglichkeiten Dinge anders zu machen, so der Spruch ist "Bier wird es immer"
Aber es gibt eine Menge Stellschrauben und Optionen?...
Es gibt eine Menge Stellschrauben und Optionen, gewisse Wege die als wo es sozusagen die Vorstellung gibt, dass das der richtige Weg ist das zu tun oder der optimale.
Ja ich meine die Vielfalt des Bieres die ist ja eh ... bekannt.
Bevor wir vielleicht darauf nochmal kommen auf die ganzen Sorten und Varianten... eine Stufe fehlt ja jetzt noch?
Ja wir haben ja erst Würze gemacht...
Wir haben ja erst Würze gemacht und danach schreit ja keiner, sondern da ist ja kein Alkohol drin und
Genau also der Spruch dazu ist " Der Brauer macht die Würze und die Hefe macht das Bier!"
Ja
So wir müssen jetzt also zu der Würze nachdem sie entweder durch den Wärmetauscher abgekühlt ist oder über Nacht abgekühlt ist, Hefe kippen, damit da Bier draus wird.
Wo kommt die jetzt her?
Und irgendwann kam sie mal aus der Luft.
Irgendwann kam sie mal von selber. genau´.
mhmh
die Firma Carlsberg war da übrigens sehr weit vorne, die haben da viel Grundlagenforschung betrieben. Die haben auch den PH-Wert erfunden.
Und ähnliche Geschichten.
mhmh
Und auch da gibt es wieder natürlich Onlineshops wo man sich das alles kaufen kann, so wie man sich das vorstellt.
Ja ok
und man hat 2 grundsätzliche Optionen, die man verwenden kann. Das eine Trockenhefe, das sind so kleine Hefepäckchen, kennt man vielleicht als Instanthefe vom Backen.
funktioniert im Prinzip genau so, das heißt man rührt das mit ein bisschen Wasser an bis es wieder hydriert ist und schüttet es dann in sein Bier rein.
und die andere Möglichkeit ist Flüssighefe, was sozusagen eher die Entsprechung ist von dem was man wenn man sich so Bäckerhefe kauft im Laden, sind das meistens so Würfel.
da sind tatsächlich Leute durch Europa gezogen von Brauerei zu Brauerei und haben überall die Hefen eingesammelt und kultivieren die jetzt und stellen die Hobbybrauern zur Verfügung.
Unglaubliches Sortiment, irgendwie gibt es 50 60 70 verschiedene Sorten Hefen, die die anbieten. und
Mittlerweile gibt es dann landesweite Kultur von kleineren und mittelgroßen Brauereien. Also so microbreweries und craftbreweries.
das sind die Begriffe die die da verwenden. Microbrewery halt irgendwie so ein Restaurant mit angeschlossener Brauerei.
mhmh
Craftbrewery dann schon etwas größer. Samuel adams ist da die Bekannteste und dann gibt's da noch große Menge.
Und ich glaub die Leute fangen an das zu merken.
Also egal ob Bierhefe oder Backhefe es kommt immer von Doktor Oetker.
Ja genau...
ungefähr so
Ja also wir haben durchaus noch Bierkultur in Deutschland so die Franken sind da ganz weit vorne mit dabei, das auch aufrecht zu erhalten.
Aber insbesondere in Norddeutschland siehts, gibt's ganze Landstriche wo es echt traurig aussieht, wo es einfach nur noch eine oder 2 große Brauereien gibt, die dann zu den Konzernen gehören, die dann vielleicht INBDEF gehören oder tatsächlich auch noch zu Cors oder Miller oder halt zu Radeberger.
Dort ihre eigenen Brauereien quasi gegründet haben.
Ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt nur die Deutschen waren, aber die werden da sicherlich ne Rolle gespielt haben?
Die die Briten und die Iren sicherlich auch.
Ja
Bestimmte Teile von Europa die eine große Bierkultur hatten.
mhmh
Aber man bemerkt auch sehr die britische Bierkultur.
Aber jetzt ist das so ein bisschen auch so ein treibender Faktor in diesem ganzen Homebrewerybereich?
Weil sie einfach sammeln und im Prinzip Europa katalogisieren, schon wie ein aussterbendes Objekt bevor man sich das in Europa überhaupt klar macht, dass das so ist?
Genau genau und das stirbt ja hier auch nach wie vor Bier aus. Ja also Berliner Weißes ist 2005 ausgestorben.
Und aussterben heißt ... das eigentlich diese das Bier ... ausmachende Spezialhefe... quasi verschwindet, weil sie nicht mehr...
Am Leben gehalten wird.
Am Leben gehalten wird?
Genau, das ist wie so ein Haustier, muss man regelmäßig füttern, ab und zu mal umkopieren
Bzw durch diesen fortwährenden Brauereiprozess einfahc auch am Leben erhalten?
genau genau genau..
Ähm, schließen wir nochmal kurz diesen Brauvorgang ab, also jetzt hast du die Würze, hast die Hefe gekauft...
mhmh
Und die Hefe kam in dem Fall aus... ?
ich glaube ich hab da schon eine Flüssighefe verwendet, so eine Wyeast
das ist dann so ein Packen, es ist ganz lustig.
Aber woher war die aus? Deutschland oder?
Na eine Hefe die mal aus Deutschland kam und in Amerika hochgepäppelt wurde. also tatsächlich wurde diese Hefe um die halbe Welt geschickt bis sie wieder bei mir gelandet, obwohl sie ja eigentlich von hier kommt.
Also du hast sie aus den USA bezogen?
Ich hab sie hier bezogen, aber der Lieferant hat sie in den USA gekauft.
Ah ok. und irgendwann kam sie ja auch mal aus Deutschland und dann wollte sie keiner mehr füttern und dann haben die Amerikaner gesagt hier tolle Hefe, gib mal her, wir pipettieren das gerne für euch weiter, wenn ihr zu faul und dann äh
Genau ungefähr so.
Halten die das quasi am Leben und wenn die Leute so Hefe haben wollen, dann kriegt man die.
mhmh genau
Und wie lang hält die sich so nach der Produktion?
Genau.
Ok
Und welche Menge?
Das ist also diese Päckchen sind relativ genau auf 20 Liter abgestimmt. Weil 20 Liter sind auch 5 Gallonen und das ist so die Standard-Batch-Größe bei den amerikanischen Homebrewern.
Ein Kasten.
so
Ein halber Kasten, nee ein Kasten ist 20....
20 Liter sind 2 Kästen 2 Kästen 2 Kästen...
mhmh
Und diese Packs sind also darauf abgestimmt, da ist Hefe drin und eine Nährlösung und dann haut man da drauf und dann wartet man 3 Stunden und dann wird die dick und dann ...
Man haut drauf?
und sich zu vermehren. und dann wird der Beutel dick und bläht sich auf, dann kann man ihn aufschneiden und sozusagen die gerade wachgewordene aktive Hefe in seinen in seine Würze kippen, damit dann Bier draus wird.
Warum kippt man das nicht einfach Nährlösung und Hefe rein, da hätte man diesen Effekt nicht?
Weil dann der Zuckerdruck zu hoch und so weiter und so fort. Gibt Spezialfälle wo man das möchte aber.
Und einfach mehr Hefe zu nehmen, also was ist jetzt das Argument für Nährlösung und Hefe, weil es dann billiger ist oder weil das dann...?d
Ja es ist billiger, weil man kann sozusagen in dem Moment wo man draufhaut, werden einfach genügend Hefezellen produziert.
Das heißt man verfünfacht noch im Beutel die Menge?
genau
Und dann muss man aber rechtzeitig aufschneiden, dass es nicht platzt und äh...
Genau
Dann einfach in die Würze?
Die zu welcher Temperatur jetzt ist?
Ah jetzt kommen wir in die Biersorten.
Ja
Was hast du gemacht=?
Für untergäriges Bier so Temperaturen um 12 Grad benötigt. und da muss man halt immer anfangen die Bottiche in den Keller zu tragen. Was irgendwie 20 Liter in den Keller tragen...
Was heißt "obergärig"?
Ja,das hat damit zu tun wo die Hefe sich befindet beim Gären, also so obergärig macht man halt so bei Zimmertemperatur 20 Grad rum, untergärig bei 12 Grad.
Und bei 20 Grad steigt die Hefe auf und bildet oben drauf einen Schaumteppich beim Gären.
Sieht sehr schick aus und schwimmt also oben drauf und bei 12 Grad sinkt die Hefe nach unten und befindet sich eher auf dem Boden des Gefäßes und macht da ihre Arbeit.
Ah also ober und untergärig in Bezug auf wo die Hefe sich physikalisch befindet relativ zur Würze während sie ihr Werk verrichtet?
Genau genau ...
Ok du bist also obergärig rangegangen, weil dann musstest du nicht deine Raumtemperatur auf 12 Grad absenken.
Genau
Vielleicht mal was für den Winter irgendwie.
Und dann also einfach nur reingespritzt und das ist dann also die Würze bleibt quasi einfach bei Raumtemperatur? Man muss es jetzt nicht weiter erhitzen, sondern hat halt einfach so im Wesentlichen diese Temperatur?
Genau.... genau... mhm
Hefe rein und die frisst dann gleich weiter, weil die denkt sich:" Oh prima hier gibt's ja ordentlich...
Ja die braucht so
...Zucker und so"
ein bisschen um sich zu aklimatisieren, aber wenn man eine gute Hefe hat nach so 2-3 Stunden gehts los.
Also bei bei der Vergärung von Zucker zu Alkohol entsteht auch CO2 und das blubbert oben raus. und weil... man nicht möchte, dass böse Obstfliegen in der Meische ertrinken und dabei böse Bakterien mit sich schleppen und das Bier schlecht wird, muss man sich also was ausdenken um die Außenwelt draußen zu halten. Das ist dann dieser Gärverschluss, kennt man auch von Weinballons, irgendwie Opa hatte das immer im Keller um Wein zu machen.
Also CO2 blubbert dann einfach so raus.
Also wenn man das frisch angesetzt hat so nach 12 Stunden wenn es richtig los geht dann blubbert da auch richtig viel.
mhmh
und jetzt muss man eigentlich gar nichts weiter machen, weil der Brauer hat ja sein Werk schon getan und jetzt kommt nur noch die Hefe dazu.
Jetzt kann man entspannt eine Woche warten.
Eine Woche?
Ja
dann ist die Hauptgärung vorbei.
mh
ja, ... dann ist das Bier aber noch nicht fertig ... und zwar fehlt noch der Blubber drin.
Also wenn man so ein Bier aufmacht, dann schäumt das ja und hat Bläschen, da ist Kohlensäure drin.
Aber die ganze Kohlensäure, die haben wir ja jetzt die ganze Zeit rausgeschickt?
Die haben wir die ganze Zeit rausgeschickt. das geht natürlich so nicht ne?
Mh
Und das heißt man muss jetzt einen Weg finden, die da drin zu behalten.
Aber man hätte jetzt eigentlich schon Bier?
Man hat im Prinzip Bier, man hat Jungbier.
Das schmeckt auch irgendwie schon nach Bier?
So untergäriges Bier heißt ja auch Lagerbier und das hat tatsächlich was mit dem deutschen Wort lagern zu tun, weil es kommt in den Lagerkeller und wird da gelagert und dann wird es besser.
mh
Aber so weit sind wir noch nicht, weil erstmal müssen wir den Blubber reinkriegen, bevor wir es lagern können.
Das ist die Stelle wo ... man... sich als Hobbybrauer durchaus den Ärger seiner Mitbewohner zuzuiehen kann,
mhm
Weil was man tut ist das entweder das Bier in ein Fass zu tun, wenn man Fortgeschritten ist, in ein Druckfass.
Also so die Vermeidung von Flaschenbomben ist da der Trick.
mhmh
Und was man als Anfänger machen kann ist einfach warten bis die Gärung komplett fertig ist, nichts mehr passiert.
Es blubbert nicht mehr und es blubbert auch schon seit 3 Tagen nicht mehr. Man hat mit seinem Refraktometer nachgemessen, da ändert sich auch nichts an der Zuckerkonzentration.
Und dann nimmt man eine genau definierte Menge Zucker, gibt es Tabellen, die also einem sagen, welcher Biertyp, wieviel Gramm CO2 pro Liter braucht, und wieviel Zucker man da rein tun muss, damit so viel CO2 entsteht.
Also ich hab noch niemanden getroffen, der in der Lage wäre geschmacklich zu sagen ob da nicht 10 % Traubenzucker am Bier waren oder nicht.
mh
Aber das ist das halt wie man es als Profi macht, weil man ja wegen des Reinheitsgebots kann man ja kein Traubenzucker ans Bier und so das geht ja nicht.
Ja, verstehe
ah ok also der Trick ist sozusagen man muss eine Ahnung haben, also entweder weiß man es einfach so durch göttliche Eingebung oder man benutzt diese Methode des Abzweigen von einem kleineren von einer kleineren Menge
mhmh
Und durch die Erhitzung spult man sozusagen in die Zukunft vor und sagt :" ok was ist denn da alles noch drin".
Genau genau
An Zucker aus dem die Hefe potentiell dann halt noch mehr... naja ...
CO2 und Alkohol macht genau.
ist das denn jetzt nur das ist aber jetzt nur sozusagen dieser dieser ... Zucker aus dem Alkohol wird nicht die anderen Zucker, also es geht jetzt sozusagen nur um den .. Zucker mit dem die Hefe auch wirklich arbeiten kann
mhmh
Und das versucht man zu...
Das heißt man... ... das ist auch der Grund warum man es ausprobiert. Man stellt es einfach hin und wartet, guckt sich das an
Ja
Kann jede Hefe auch immer mit Traubenzucker was anfangen?
Und dann den richtigen Zeitpunkt zu erwischen, wo wenn man das dann auf Flaschen füllt und den Deckel drauf macht dass es hinterher ausge... genau richtig schäumt.
Verstehe,
mhmh
Dann doch lieber wenn man alleine wohnt, weil sonst knallts.
Jaaa oder ein Keller wo es dann egal ist, wenn mal ein paar Flaschen platzen.
Oder wenn man falsch liegt nicht genug Kohlensäure überhaupt erzeugt wird, weil man viel zu spät gekommen ist?
Das passiert sogar Profis ab und zu.
mh
also du hast es dann erstmal mit Traubenzucker gemacht?
Ja Traubenzucker ist auf jeden Fall der einfachere Ansatz.
Ok
Das macht man rein, Deckel drauf.
mh
Fertig.
Genau
Ah man friert sozusagen die Vergangenheit ein und dann ist
Genau genau
Genau das geht auch noch.
mh
das verliert dann auch keine nennenswerte Qualität durch das Einfrieren?
Das ist ja jetzt eigentlich auch nur der Anteil der für den Prickel sorgt.
Mhmh
Wie lange muss das dann noch stehen bis das dann so...?
Das muss dann 2 Wochen in etwa in die Nachgärung, so lange dauert das bis der Druck drauf ist.
Und dann muss es in die Kaltlagerung, so dann ist das Bier im Prinzip schon fertig. Also es schäumt schon wenn man es einschenkt, aber es schmeckt noch nach Jungbier.
Was irgendwie ein schwer zu beschreibender Geschmack ist, aber es ist einfach dann nicht so rund und angenehm und schmeichelt den Gaumen nicht so, sondern eher noch ein bisschen garstig.
wir können es kosten, ich hab ja hier ein bisschen was mitgebracht.
Ja
Das hier ist ein ein Jungbier, dass sich jetzt seit 2 Tagen in der Nachgärung befindet.
Ok. das hier ist ein kleiner Flachmann.
würd ich mal sagen. Mit so einer bräunlichen Flüssigkeit... wie sieht denn das aus?
Ja das trifft es.
nu
in der Fump-Flasche so und das ist das Ergebnis wovon genau?
das ist jetzt sozusagen während der Nachgärung abgezwackt. Das Bier handelt um das es sich handelt ist ein sogenanntes IPA ein India Pale Ale
Also Ale ist erstmal der britische Begriff für obergärige Biere. Ein pale ale ist ein helles Bier und ein india pale ale ist ein Bier, das im british empire bis nach Indien verschifft werden sollte und das deswegen etwas stärker gehopft war, damit es den langen Seeweg unbeschadet überlebt.
Ah mehr Hopfen.
Mehr Hopfen und vorallem sogenanntes Dry(???) Hopping, da wird in das Gärfass noch mal Hopfen gegeben, also in den Prozess den ich eben beschrieben habe, kam der Hopfen ja beim Hopfenkochen vor.
mhmh
Und dann zum Schluss mit der Würze kam ja bloß noch Hefe dazu, was man beim Dry Hopping oder Hopfenstopfen auf deutsch macht, ist noch mal Hopfen in das Gärfass mit reinwerfen.
Wodurch keine Bitterstoffe mehr gelöst werden, wodurch aber Aromen gelöst werden und ich glaub du wirst es schmecken, wenn du es aufmachst, das ist halt irgendwie....
hopfig
Ok also jetzt kommt hier der erste Selbstversuch.
mhmh
plomp
Hat schon mal plomp gemacht. Nimm ein Glas.
riecht ... riecht ja auch ein bisschen wie Apfelsaft.
Ja es ist sehr fruchtig, das ist ein
Ja ...
sehr
mh
würde ja immer noch meinen es ist Apfelsaft jetzt probier ich das mal...
ist so ein also so ein Hauch... ... also Sprudel wär jetzt übertrieben zu sagen, aber so ein bisschen bierig schmeckt es schon...
strange...
Aber es ist schon... schon interessantes Getränk, aber man merkt dass es noch nicht unbedingt so ein Endprodukt ist.
Es ist noch nicht fertig, ja. Es hat noch zu wenig blubber es hat die Kaltreifung nicht durch.
mhmh
Cascade cascadia ist also so eine Gegend in an der Westküste, so ein bisschen nördlich von San Francisco bis hoch nach New York State, ist das Cascadia und da kommt dieser Hopfen her, und der hat einen sehr ausgeprägten fruchtigen Charakter,
Also die meisten Leute sagen Litchi oder Pfirsich oder Aprikose.
Ja
und was hat das jetzt für ein Alkoholanteil in etwa?
Ja, ich bin ja eh nicht so ein Freund von dem belgischen Ansatz.
Ach doch ich mag das sehr, ich hatte neulich ein sehr leckeres belgischen Trappistenbier auf expliziten Wunsch meiner Frau.
Und das war sozusagen das Gegenteil davon, das war kein Stück hopfig und pechschwarz und sehr malzig und mit 9,5% Alkohol.
Ja also jetzt haben wir ja schon, wir haben jetzt im Prinzip, die Brausession ist jetzt vorüber.
wenn die Dinger jetzt lang genug gestanden haben, ab einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt müssen die einfach nur noch stehen?
genau im kalten stehen.
Muss man... aber man kann sie jetzt auch nicht ewig stehen lassen, weil so richtig...
Das hängt ein bisschen vom Bier ab, also viele Bier altern tatsächlich relativ fix und sind dann nicht mehr genießbar... also so was wie das was du trinkst grade durch also diese floralen fruchtigen hopfengeschmacksanteiligen, die gehen relativ schnell verloren, also in 3 Monaten schmeckt man davon nichts mehr.
mhm
es gibt aber durchaus Biere die kann man erst mal ein paar Jahre in den Keller legen und die werden dann nur besser, also insbesondere so grade sehr starke Bier, sehr malzige Biere
So Barley Wines zum Beispiel ist so eine Kategorie von englischen Bieren, die sehr stark sind, die ganzen belgischen Trappistenbiere, kann man lange Jahre lagern.
Es gibt von,...
Was meinst du genau mit sehr malzige Biere, also...?
Ich hab jetzt keins da, aber doch das was ich hier trinke, das dieser 14 halligen(???)er Bier Nothelfertrunk, der hat eher schon so einen malzigen Charakter als einen hopfigen Charakter.
Im also ich meine und zwar deshalb, weil da jetzt mehr Malz verwendet wird?
Ne andere Malze, die ... die man schmeckt. also in der Regel etwas dunkler geröstete Malze, da kommt dieses Malzaroma raus.
Weiß nicht kennst du diese Malzbonbons?
Ja
In den Blauweißen Packungen, das ist so ungefähr die Essenz dieses Geschmacks.
die halt von den dunklen Malzen kommt, die man halt in einem Pils genau gar nicht findet.
Die man in dunklen Bieren findet gerne in Stouts zum Beispiel, also ein Stout ist ein ausgeprägt malziges Bier...
So Guinness nicht besonders, weil das ist wieder ein Massenbier, aber so die ... gibt schon mal die ungefähre Richtung, so röstige Aromen malzige Aromen, so Kaffee Schokolade Espresso, ein bisschen in die Richtung geschmacklich.
ja...
Die halten sich, die kann man lagern.
Mhmh
die ... also wir hatten ja vorhin schon diese Sache mit den mit diesen Helligkeiten, die sich ja quasi aus dem Malz oder aus der entsprechenden Mischung verschiedener Malze ergeben.
Aber das ist ja jetzt nicht, ... ich kann ja nicht einer Farbe direkt ansehen, was da jetzt eigentlich für ein Bier dahinter steckt, auch wenn man ja meistens irgendwie die ganzen Schwarzen sind dann halt irgendwie diese ja prickelfreien Biere aus Irland.
mhm
oder weiß nicht wo die noch gebraut werden, Schottland vielleicht keine Ahnung... überhaupt so Britannien.
Stouts, genau Stout ist eine britische Geschichte, dass Stout ist .... schwierig. Also Porter und Stout sind nahezu Synonyme Biere.
Und es gab ein besonders gutes Porter, das hieß dann Stoutporter ... und dann wollten die Leute irgendwann kein Porter mehr trinken sondern nur noch Stout, weil es das bessere Bier war.
Und dann ist aber auch die Qualität der Stouts soweit gesunken, dass man also historisch nicht sagen ob jetzt ein Bier Stout oder Porter genannt werden kann, hängt davon ab... so wo genau man sich in den letzten 200 Jahren befindet und heutzutage hat es keinen nennenswerten Definitionsunterschied mehr.
Aber das ist tatsächlich eine britische Geschichte, die in London angefangen hat und auch Irland und Schottland erobert hat.
Aber ab welchem Punkt unterscheidet man eine Biersorte? Ich mein das hat was mit dem Malz zu tun, das hat was mit der eingesetzten Hefe zu tun, das hat wahrscheinlich auch mit der Hopfensorte zu tun und der Menge die man von allem jeweils zugibt, plus wie man so das Timing von allem macht?
genau, also es gibt ... ... also eine deutlich 2 stellige Anzahl anerkannter Bierstile, das ist dann halt immer abhängig davon mit wem man redet.
Was ein eigener Bierstil ist und was nicht, wie das immer so ist.
Ja
Aber tatsächlich sind das so die Merkmale, also die Farbe des Bieres, das Aromaprofil, die Stärke, die ähm...
Kohlensäureanteil?
Ja da gibt's auch viele typische Werte so.
mhmh
das Verfahren, das man verwendet um das Bier zu machen, was halt im Vordergrund steht an Geschmäckern, und so weiter und so fort.
Und was würdest du sagen sind so die wichtigsten Biersorten die so ....?
Uh die wichtigsten ...
Die man zumindest mal auseinander halten sollte?
Ja so die meisten Leute in Deutschland kennen ja bloß noch Pils.
ist insofern ein Extrembier, weil es halt ganz am Anschlag ist, was die Farbe angeht, also es ist ein sehr sehr helles Bier, was sehr sehr wenig malzbetont ist.
Was gibt's in Deutschland noch? Auch das das Standardhelle, das süddeutsche Helle ist halt im Prinzip ein Pils mit nicht ganz so viel Hopfen.
Was was mit der Wasserchemie zu tun hat, zwar wird der Hopfen kratzig, wenn die Restalkalität des Wassers zu hoch ist, also
die chemische Zusammensetzung des Wassers sorgt dann dafür, dass der PH-Wert beim Meischen nicht die richtigen Werte erreicht. Und deswegen werden Bitterstoffe ausgelaugt und das Bier schmeckt kratzig.
Was hat denn diese Pilsrevolution ausgelöst, also?
Das...
Ist das irgendwie einfach das Bier, was den Geschmack getroffen hat? Kann man das so sagen oder?
also es gibt...
also der Geburtsort des Pils?
Genau genau das Pils heißt Pils, wegen der Stadt Pilsen wo das Urquell herkommt.
Ja
ist auch keine besonders traditionelle Geschichte, also in Pilsen wurde schon immer Bier gebraut. Aber Pilsener also wie man es heute kennt wird da seit 150 Jahren erst gebraut 160.
mhmh
... war also da hat die Stadt zusammengelegt. Die Bürger der Stadt haben gesagt:"Wir bauen uns jetzt eine Brauerei auf"
Haben sich aus Bayern einen Braumeistern geholt, wo das mit den untergährigen schon ne länge Weiler ne Weile länger in Gebrauch war-.
weils da die passenden Felsenkeller gab, wo man einfach die Temperaturen hatte.
und ... das besonders weiche Wasser, was es in Pilsen gab erlaubte halt, dass man ähm
ein sehr sehr helles Bier machen konnte mit einem hohen Hopfenanteil ohne das es kratzig wurde.
aha
Also es hat mit dem Wasser zu tun es hat was damit zu tun, dass das Brauverfahren dort hin importiert wurde und dann halt ... also quasi ein - wenn man sich das so als multidimensionales Universum vorstellt dieses Bier wo
Irgendwie so Farbe und Geschmack und Hopfenanteile und Bitterkeit und CO2 jeweils die Dimensionen sind.
Hat das Bier einfach geschafft einen Winkel zu besetzen eine Ecke, die noch keiner vorher besetzt hat. Die eine sehr Extreme war, weil so hell und so viel Hopfen hat halt keiner vorher gemacht.
Also das Pils, weil das Pils innerhalb des Bieruniversums.
Innerhalb des Bieruniversums.
mhmh
Also bevor der Herr Linde nicht die Kältemaschine erfunden hatte, brauchte man halt einen Felsenkeller und einen See der im Winter zufriert, wo man dann das Eis aus dem See in den Felsenkeller schaffen konnte, damit man den Sommer über das Bier kühlen konnte.
Ja
Und das ging halt in den bayrischen Alpen und aber in vielen Orten ging es nicht.
Und in dem Moment wo jeder seinen Kühlschrank anschmeißen konnte und man die Temperatur einfach so halten konnte, wie man es brauchte...
... stand das jedem offen.
Genau
Also Pils ist auch untergärig?
Pils ist ein untergäriges Bier...
Und wird dann lange gelagert?
Ja heißt aber nicht Lagerbier.
Na im Prinzip schon es kommt immer darauf an wen man fragt. Es ist also von der Kategorisierung her ist es ein Lager,...
mh
Und aber Pils ist halt nochmal so eine so eine eigene Unterkategorie.
Verstehe
Ja es gibt übrigens auch obergährige Lagerbiere. ... Kölsch.
Aber jetzt wollten die natürlich auch alle so irgendwie dieses schicke neue moderne Bier von da unten, das Helle dieses Pils machen und durften aber nicht.
Also haben sie sich überlegt "machen wir ein obergäriges Bier, was wir trotzdem hinterher lagern, bei 0Grad bei 6 Wochen oder 3Monate. Und so ist das Kölsch entstanden vor 150 Jahren.
Und dann aber auch schon mit der Kältemaschine oder?
Auch schon mit der Kältemaschine für den Lagerungsprozess.
Ja
Aber noch nicht für die Gärung, weil die Gärung ist da noch bei Zimmertemperatur, weil das Reinheitsgebot das Kölner Reinheitsgebot, verbot die Herstellung untergäriger Biere.
Warum?
Weil das war vom Teufel das kam aus Bayern. oder wie?
Ja ungefähr so, ist halt verboten, so.
darfst du hier nicht.
frag mich mal warum ich kein Koreander in mein Bier tun kann.
oder Haferflocken.
Du bist nicht so ein Freund vom Reinheitsgebot, wenn ich das so richtig raushöre.
Ich bin da kein großer Freund von... ja also es gibt sicherlich diverse Biere auf dem Planeten, die vom Reinheitsgebot qualitativ profitieren würden, aber das Reinheitsgebot sagt nicht "nimm tolle Zutaten für dein Bier" sondern das Reinheitsgebot sagt "nimm irgendwie Gerstewasser und Hefe" und wenn aber...
Also genau genommen ist das Reinheitsgebot eigentlich kein Reinheitsgebot im Sinne von, das es rein ist, sondern es ist eigentlich eine Rezepturvorschrift die einfach andere möglicherweise äquivalente oder doch zumindest auch ausprobierenswürdige Zutaten schlicht verbietet?
mhm
Wegen ist so.
Wegen ist so genau
zum Beispiel also das Reinheitsgebot heißt ja bei uns nicht Reinheitsgebot sondern das heißt vorläufiges Biersteuergesetz.
Ernsthaft?
ernsthaft!
und es sagt zum Beispiel, dass du ein Weizenbier nicht untergärig herstellen darfst.
so... Weizenbier muss immer obergärig sein.
und wenn man untergäriges Bier machen will, muss es immer 100% Gerstenbier sein. Da fragt man sich "Warum?"
ja warum?
so und es gibt einfach keinen sinnvollen Grund, außer das ist so.
...ah
Ja und warum es zu diesem Gesetz mal gekommen ist, da gibt es diverse Theorien...
Also siehst du das da irgendwann mal was explodieren wird oder so oder das danach alle durch die Straße laufen oder so?
Ja nee das ist irgenwie so, es ist nicht erlaubt, weil es verboten ist.
Aha
Und es ist verboten, weil könnten ja schlimme Dinge passieren, zum Beispiel könnte man verhaftet werden, weil ist ja verboten.
oder irgendwelche anderen Firmen könnten irgendwie anfangen irgendwas zu produzieren, was die anderen nicht machen.
Also der Witz ist ja, dass man durch die EUHarmonisierung mittlerweile das was in anderen Ländern als Bier verkauft werden kann auch hier verkaufen darf.
Also man darf ein belgisches Bier, was also dann keine Ahnung Kandiszucker und Haferflocken und Koreander enthält zum Beispiel, und wir reden von durchaus leckeren qualitativ hochwertigen Bieren, die darfst du hier verkaufen, weil ist ja EU.
Aber?
Du darfst es hier nicht herstellen als Bier.
mh
Ja so in Deutschland ist da ist es streng verboten, muss man "kein Bier" drauf schreiben oder sowas. Ich werd das nochmal rausfinden.
Es gibt ja jetzt auch Matebier?
Ja Matebier ist aber ein Biermischgetränk, das geht noch.
Also du darfst hinterher, wenn das Bier fertig ist, es mit einem anderen Getränk mixen und es Biermischgetränk nennen, das geht.
wenn du jetzt aber anfängst die Mate mit reinzuwerfen beim Hopfenkochen, dann landest du also ruckzuck in schwierigen Grauzonen.
Ah verstehe
Ich find also den schwarzen Abt selber find ich nicht so lecker es gibt das helle Bier nochmal ohne Zuckerzusatz von dieser Firma, das ist wesentlich besser.
Und die mussten sich aber echt vor Gericht rumstreiten, dafür dass sie ihr Bier Bier nennen dürfen, weil sie halt Ingwerzuckersirup dazu geben und mussten sich also auf eine Aufnahmeklausel berufen in der drin steht:
wenn ein Bier traditionell so hergestellt wird, dann darf man es auch weiter Bier nennen."
Muss dann also erstmal irgendwie alte Unterlagen von vor 200 oder 300 Jahren rauskramen, beweisen das bei ihnen das Bier schon immer so gemacht wurde und dann ging es auf einmal.
das ist ja interessant, dass man das irgendwie EU-weit eigentlich alles tun darf nur nicht von Deutschland aus...
Ja das ist total absurd.
Und also man darf halt auch echt den letzten Scheiß in sein Bier reinschütten, solange es nominell das Reinheitsgebot erfüllt von der Rezeptur her ja. Also ob das irgendwie der letzte zusammengekehrte Gerstenrest ist und irgendwelche komischen Hopfenblätter die man irgendwo gefunden hat, das spielt dann keine Rolle mehr, das ist nach wie vor Reinheitsgebot.
Ah
Und was man auch darf ist Zusätze verwenden solange sie zu 100% wieder rausgefiltert werden.
Also sehr üblich ist die Zugabe einer Substanz namens PVPP zum Bier. Was so eine Art Plasteschleim ist, der halt mit den ganzen Trübstoffen eine Verbindung eingeht, so damit man damit das Bier nicht trüb wird.
mh
wirds gefiltert und damit die Filterwirkung besser ist, damit es größere Klumpen gibt, wird vorher das PVPP reingeschüttet.
Also man schüttet eine Plastesoße ins Bier, jagt das dann durch den Filter, wo die Plastesoße zusammen mit dem was man rausfiltern will im Filter hängenbleibt. und man darf das immernoch hinterher Reinheitsgebot nennen.
Sagst du jetzt Plaste um das irgendwie plastisch zu machen wie man sich das vorstellen muss oder handelt es sich hierbei um einen Kunststoff?
Es handelt sich um einen Kunststoff, du kann'st ja gerne mal PVPP googlen. Das ist polyvinylhasemal
stöhnt
hast du nicht gesehen.
auweia
Genau genau das.
Auch Crospovidon genannt... soso
Ja...
Lebensmittelzusatzstoff E1202 guck an.
ok also das ist auf jeden Fall alles ausreichend absurd und es gibt eigentlich keinen wirklich guten rationalen Grund, aber irgendwie hat man das alles so ...
Ja es ist halt ein guter Marketingspruch.
...verkauft. Ja ist rein.
Ja
Auch wenn es der letzte Dreck ist, Hauptsache rein.
Ja und so ein tolles Wort und ich mein Reinheitsgebot das versteht sogar ein Amerikaner. Das ist einfach das klingt schon so deutsch.
Klingt es wahrscheinlich bedrohlich.
Ach weia.
genau.
Ok dann ...
Genau Biere dieser Welt, beziehungsweise auch so Biere die, ich meine es gibt ja jetzt grad da im Kölschbereich gibt es ja dann auch noch das Altbier, das ist ja nur ein paar Meter weiter,
mh
Ja aber da gibt es dann schon wieder so einen religiösen Krieg, das ja in diesem Bereich da auch sehr...
Also ich hab...
... nah beieinander.
Ich hab ja eine Meinung in diesem religiösen Krieg. Und ich weiß nicht ob ich die äußern kann ohne Gefahr zu laufen..
Hallo hier hören keine Kölner zu und Düsseldorfer auch nicht.
Doch bestimmt du wirst unglaublich böse Mail kriegen.
Her damit.
ich fang mal so...
Aber irgendwie so Alt hab ich schon echt bessere getrunken. So Uerige hat da echt die Nase vorne, was den Geschmack angeht.
Uerige?
Uerige ist ein Alt aus Düsseldorf.
Ah
Mh
Ist ein bisschen zu einer Tourifalle geworden, aber das Bier ist immer noch sehr gut.
Weißt du auch warum das Altbier Altbier heißt?
Nee ich hab keine Ahnung.
Weil das neue Verfahren, weil das Untergärige wo man jetzt die Kältemaschinen hat und so wie man das Bier früher gemacht hat, nämlich obergärig ist dann das alte Bier,
Ah
Also Altbier ist auch ein obergäriges Bier, genau wie Kölsch.
Verstehe, das ist dann aber wahrscheinlich diese Grundlage dieser Auseinandersetzung dieser kulturellen, so nach dem Motto, so das ist sozusagen das Althergebracht, so wie wir es immer schon gemacht haben.
mh
Und das andere ist so ein bisschen der Poser, der versucht so ein bisschen das Pils zu sein.
genau
Jetzt krieg ich auch böse Mail.
Ich mag aber Kölsch trotzdem.
das ist ok man kann das.
Ich mein es ist ja alles irgendwie lecker und letzenendes hängt es immer davon ab in welcher Verfassung man sich gerade befindet bzw wie die Sonne so steht. also ja...
genau.
Machen wir mal bei deutschen Bierstilen weiter, ich glaub da bevor wir uns sozusagen dem Rest des Universums widmen
allerdings.
also herber heißt mehr Hopfen?
Herb heißt mehr Hopfen genau und da brauch man also heutzutage gibt es natürlich Wasseraufbereitung und irgendwie Ionentauscher und alles mögliche und man kann jedes Bier überall brauen mit entsprechend technischem Aufwand.
War früher nicht so ... wobei irgendwie wenn man in Bremen ist und so ein Becks trinkt stellt man fest, dass sie sich manchmal auch nicht dafür interessiert haben, dass es kratzt beim trinken.
So also ...für mich nicht ganz nachvollziehbar.
Naja anyways, aber eigentlich gab es in Norddeutschland...
Ah jetzt wo du das sagst, ich mein ich bin ich hab ja schon gesagt ich bin ja so ein schlechter Schmäcker, und muss auch sagen ich hab jetzt diesen ganzen Biergenuss auch nicht zuviel Aufmerksamkeit geschenkt.
Ich weiß zwar wann es mir schmeckt und wann nicht aber ja wenn man jetzt so sagen wir mal so ein Industriebier trinkt und das dann mag, dann schauen einen ja dann so Kenner dann auch schnell mal ein bisschen schräg an so mit: " Wie bist du denn drauf?"
Und das lag auch so ein bisschen daran, dass ich mir a) den Unterschied wahrscheinlich nie so richtig klar gemacht hab b) auch selten so richtig in den Vergleich gegangen bin, ja.
mh
Ist mir ja neulich auch mal so eine die von dir am Rande schon erwähnte, fränkische Bierkiste zugeschickt wurde, ja wo so diese ganzen Kleinbrauereien da drin sind und ich da also bei manchen der Sorten, aber eigentlich bei fast allen... und auch schon bei dem Bier was du mir da schon mal gegeben hast es so unglaublich auffällig war wie weich, ist das eine gute Bezeichnung, also so im Sinne von unkratzig?
Dass einem so...
Ja also
entgegen kommt?
Die die meisten Industriebiere schaffen es da auch unauffällig zu sein, also Becks sticht da von den Industriebieren dadurch raus, dass es ich find es einfach, das ist kratzig das schmeckt nicht.
Während so wenn man sich so die Standardpilse anguckt, also das was man so die Fernsehpilse nennt, was im Fernsehen beworben wird, da findet man eigentlich relativ wenig Unterschied und die sind eigentlich darauf getrimmt möglichst wenig im Weg zu sein, also möglichst wenig Geschmack zu haben.
Und also die das Kratzige das Bittere ist ein Problem das man halt in den Griff kriegen muss man kann einfach ein Dunkelbier machen, das kratzt dann nicht, weil da der PH-Wert beim Maischen anders ist.
aber klar diese ganzen kleinen Bier die sind wesentlich .... runder und gefälliger, weil da ,.... ja ich glaube auch einfach sorgfältiger und noch handwerklicher daran gearbeitet wird.
mhmh...
aus dem Kasten den der Tim geschickt bekommen hat, dem fränkischen hab ich jetzt grad ein altfränkisches Bauernbier dunkel, aus dem Hause Heldbräu.
Da sind wir nämlich beim nächsten Bierstil, die Dunkelbiere, also Deutschland wird ja vornehmlich untergärig gebraut,
Ausnahmen hatten wir schon Kölsch und Alt, die weitere Ausnahme ist die Berliner Weiße, zu der kommen wir gleich.
Alles andere ist untergärig und es gibt auch nicht nur die Hellen untergärigen Biere wie Pils und Helles, sondern auch dunkle untergärige Biere.
Davon mach ich mir jetzt mal eins auf.
Fump
Ha
ja
Treffer
aber es hat nicht fump gemacht.
Nagut ... die sind in der Regel also wenn man sie mit anderen dunklen Bieren vergleicht, also so ein Porter zum Beispiel, was ja ein britisches dunkles Bier wäre.
wenn man das gegen so ein deutsches Dunkelbier dagegen stellt, dann fällt auf, dass durch die untergärige Produktionsweise, einfach weniger Esther drin sind, das Bier ist insgesamt ein bisschen schlanker und gefälliger, macht auch nicht so Kopfweh am nächsten Tag.
mh
Prost
Porter
dunkles Bier
mh
Was ist hier... ich mag ja eigentlich diese britischen Schwarzbiere, ganz toll
Auch so auch wenns das Bier auch mal nicht so prickelnd zischig daher kommt, find ich manchmal auch echt sehr angemessen.
Ja das ist in Großbritannien...
Wobei es da ja riesige Unterschiede zu geben scheint, zwischen dem was man so aus Flasche trinkt und dem was man so aus dem Fass kriegt. Oder ist das alles Einbildung...
Auf jeden Fall das ist keine Einbildung. So das ist den britischen Biertrinkern in den 50er 60er Jahren auch aufgefallen, da sind die Brauereien dazu übergegangen, statte dem klassischen Verfahren Edelstahldrucktanks an die Kneipen auszuliefern
und also das was es hier auch gibt, und die Trinker waren damit nicht zufrieden und es gibt seitdem, also die CAMRA Campaign For Real Ale
und da ist es so, dass das Bier sozusagen noch in Gärung befindlich in Fässern in die Kneipen gebracht wird und der Wirt dann dafür verantwortlich ist die Gärung zum Abschluss zu bringen
nein
Und dann wird aus dem Fass auch ohne CO2 Flasche ausgeschenkt sondern es gibt da diese Beerengine, kennst du bestimmt, ein großer Hebel, wo man dran zieht und pumpen muss.
Ja
Dann wird das Fass wird das Bier aus dem Fass unter Atmosphärendruck nach oben gepumpt und dann strömt auch Luft ein und so weiter und so fort, muss dann also schnell ausgetrunken werden, aber das ist halt ein lebendiges quasi gerade mit der Gärung fertiges Bier, was dann mechanisch hochgepumpt wird.
Ah ich dachte das wär irgendwie nur so ein Film den die da fahren, so mit dass das irgendwie cool aussieht und so...?
nenenenee das ist hat tatsächlich Gründe und zwar
mhm
der Grund ist nicht durch also in dem Moment wo man halt mit CO2 und mit Druck arbeitet um das Bier aus dem Fass rauszubekommen, löst sich auch was von dem CO2 im Bier.
Und dann ja ... ... ist es... also irgendwann ist das Bier halt überkarbonisiert und lässt sich nicht mehr so angenehm trinken.
Und es gibt durchaus Leute, die auf dieses etwas nicht ganz so pricklige stehen, weil es verträglicher ist.
Ja
Und weil es halt ein lebendiges Bier ist ist es auch viel leckererer.
also Bier wird...
Ja lecker ist das.
Ja ja Bier wird halt gefiltert um es haltbar zu machen, also die Geschichte mit dem PVPP was da reingeschüttet wird und rausgefiltert, da geht es halt darum dass das Bier auch mal 6 Monate in der Tanke in der Sonne stehen kann, hinterher immer noch schmeckt.
So halt irgendwie industrielles Massenprodukt
Das haltbar ist und diese britischen real ales sind halt das komplette Gegenteil davon.
mh
Die wichtigsten Bierstile: es gibt so ....... oh das ist jetzt schwierig, das krieg ich glaub ich nicht vollständig zusammen, es gibt eine ganz großartige Webseite, die heißt shutupaboutBarcleyPerkins
barclayperkins.blogspot.de ist die URL glaub ich und betrieben von einem gewissen Ron Pettenson der Bierarchäologie macht und sich unter anderem auf die britischen Biere spezialisiert hat.
Und dann immer mal so Anfälle kriegt und ein Jahr lang schottische Biere recherchiert, aber dann so richtig hardcore in die Archive geht, die alten Braubücher rausholt, sich die Aufzeichnungen anguckt, irgendwie riesige Tabellen hat, die über Stammwürzegehalt der Biere, und Farbe der Biere und Alkoholgehalt der Biere und so weiter und so fort.
Ganz großartige Seite und der versucht ab und zu das mit der Klassifizierung und es scheitert regelmäßig daran, dass sich das einfach zu oft und zu schnell ändert. Also es gibt ...
eine Einteilung da nach Schilling, also irgendwie so ein 20 Schilling 40 Schilling 60 Schilling Bier,was wiederum tatsächlich der Preis des Bieres war, was dann mit der Menge der Zutaten zu tun hat.
mhmh
Und dem Stammwürzegehalt, also wieviel Zucker dann in der Bierbrühe drin ist.
mhmhj
es gibt die bitters, esb so extra special bitter oder special bitter es ist so eine Richtung.
Also sie unterscheiden ja auch zwischen ale und beer. So ale ist halt eher so obergärig nicht so hopfenbetont ist eher malziges und so ein beer ist eher das was sie sich dann importiert haben mit dem Hopfenkram.
mhmh
genau die porter hatten wir schon erwähnt, porter stout
Die Schwarzen.
Die schwarzen gab es oder gibt es immer noch in einer Variante, also die wurden dann über die Ostsee exportiert bis nach Russland.
Und auch wieder ein bisschen stärker eingebraut damit sie den Weg überlieben überlebten, dass hieß dann imperial porter und das gibt es immer noch, also in Polen kann man zum Beispiel immer noch baltic porter kaufen,
Also so ein auch ein deutsches Dunkelbier ist in der Regel noch ein Bier was man gegen den Durst trinken kann,
und so ein Porter gegen den Durst, da wird man schon ganz schön schnell betrunken von.
Richtig viel dunkle schwarze Biere gibt es aber nicht in Deutschland oder?
es gibt in der fränkischen Region eine sehr starke Tradition, wie gesagt dunkles Bier war in München einst sehr beliebt ist nahezu ausgestorben.
mhmh
die fränkischen Dunkelbiere und es gibt in im Osten tatsächlich noch eine Tradition dunkler Biere.
Also das Lausitzer Porter kennt man vielleicht Schwarzbier
Duckstein kenn ich noch
Duckstein ist aber kein Dunkelbier, das ist eher so ein rötliches mit
Das gibt es aber auch als dunkel...
Gibt es das auch als dunkel? das hab ich als dunkel noch nicht gesehen, ich kenn nur das etwsa rötliches mit Buchenholzreifung, ist ganz lecker, ist jetzt nicht so die Oberkrönung.
Aber auf jeden Fall ein deutlich trinkbareres Bier, als vieles andere.
Köstritzer ist so das bekannteste Schwarzbier.
Gibt Bernauer Schwarzbier gab es noch dann gibt es den märkischen Landmann. Und so ähnliche Biere...
Da kommt ja auch die Mate her.
Was wie von wo?
aus Köstritz.
Aus Köstritz?
ja
Ich dachte die kommt aus Münchsteinach?
Ja.
ok das wusste ich nicht. das ist spannend.
das Eibauer Schwarzbier soll noch ganz gut sein, das hab ich noch nicht getrunken.
Aber das ist auch noch eins von den klassischen Schwarzbieren.
mh
Es gibt einen Haufen ausgestorbener Biere oder fast ausgestorben und jetzt wiederbelebt.
Also ein echter Exot ist Mumme die Braunschweiger Mumme.
Und zwar ist das ein Bier mit einem also das mit einem sehr sehr hohen Zuckeranteil in der Würze produziert wurde, von dem aber nur ein sehr geringer Teil in Alkohol umgesetzt wurde.
Mumme?
Mumme. M U M M E
Ja
Braunschweiger Mumme und das also gerne verwendet wurde zum Beispiel auf Schiffen, weil es einfach sehr sehr nahrhaft war, ja also hat man nicht nur was getrunken, sondern hat man auch gleich gegessen.
Mhmh
Bockbiere sind noch so eine Spezialität die sicherlich viele Leute kennen.
mhmh
Gibt es in verschiedenen Varianten. Der Maibock der eher frisch und hell und hopfig kommt.
Und dann der... die Winterböcke, die dann eher malzig schwer und dunkel sind.
bis hin zum Doppelbock.
also Bockbiere sind vor allem... ?
stärkere Biere.
Mehr Alkohol?
Mehr Alkohol und auch ein bisschen mehr Zucker dann entsprechend.
mhmh
Also so ein einfacher Bock hat dann so 7 6,5-7% und ein Doppelbock 7,5-8 .
Warum heißen die so?
dazu gibt es mehrere Theorien, die plausibelste ist, dass das Bockbier Bockbier von der Stadt Einbeck hieß.
Also Einbeck hat einstmals Bier exportiert im großen Maßstab und wurde dann Einpöcker Bier genannt und daraus wurde Bockbier.
Ah ok verstehe.
Das ist so die...
Klingt nachvollziehbar.
Die die gängige Theorie.
Ja
Ja und dann gibt es die nahezu ausgestorbenen Biere bzw ausgestorbenen Biere die gesamte Kategorie der Sauerbiere.
Die Berliner Weiße ist sicherlich das was man vielleicht gerade noch so kennt, was es aber auch nur noch rudimentär gibt, also es gibt noch ein Bier, das als Berliner Weiße hergestellt und verkauft wird in Berlin nämlich von Kindl.
Das aber untergärig statt obergärig hergestellt wird mit Getrenntvermetnation statt Mischvermentation. Also bei den Sauerbieren spielt halt die Milchsäurevermentation auch eine Rolle, da will man also, dass nicht nur die Hefen sondern auch bestimmte Bakterien das Bier besiedeln das wir dann sauer.
Ok spannend.
Weil ich komme ja aus Hannover.
Ja
Und damals hatte ich,
Mhmh
Jetzt haste grad einen Bezug hergestellt.
Und der Herr Broyhahn hat also ein Weißbier produziert also aus Luftmalz wie wir gelernt haben und solches Bier und das hat sich tatsächlich ....
Also Broyhahn schreibt sich B R O Y ne
Genau - also mein...
B R O manchmal wird er auch mit I geschrieben.
Der hieß nur zufällig so so haha also das ist der Herr Broyhahn sich auch mit Brauen beschäftigt hat... ja
Ja
Mag andere Gründe gehabt haben als den Namen.
Genau ... wie gesagt saure Biere die dann in Nord... ... also im nördlichen Raum deutschlands beziehungsweise was auch immer das damals war. sehr sehr populär geworden sind und zwar ... im Prinzip durchgehend von dem was heute Belgien ist bis dem was heute Polen ist.
die Belgier machen auch nach wie vor Sauerbiere, da gibt es die ganze Abteilung der Lambics, die Sauerbiere sind und oder Gueze ......
Es gab noch ein paar Rester, also bis in die 70er Jahre gabe es zum Beispiel eine Bremer Weiße, die ähnlich wie Berliner Weiße funktioniert und geschmeckt hat.
Es gab in Leipzig die ähm... die Gosslarer Gose, also interessanterweise nicht in Gosslar sondern aus Gosslar ist die Gose gewandert und ist dann zu einem Sauerbier geworden und wurde dann im Harz produziert bzw in Leipzig in der Nähe von Leipzig.
Also spannend auch die Verwandtschaft der Namen hier ja also die die Leipziger Gose und das belgische Gueze ist im Prinzip das selbe Wort und dasselbe Bier.
Mhmh
auch ein Sauerbier, dann gab es das Lichtenhainer Bier, dass die Lichtenhain ist ein Vorort vor Jena und die Studenten vor 150 Jahren, man erinnert sich als Studentenverbindungen nicht reaktionärer Scheiß waren sondern progressive Gesellschaftselemente.
Ja
Sind sie immer vor der den Toren der Stadt, weil in Jena durften sie nicht saufen, also sind sie vor den Toren der Stadt in Lichtenhain saufen gegangen.
Und das Bier, das es da gab das Lichtenhainer ist auch ein Sauerbier.
Das gibt es auch noch, da gibt es eine kleine Gaststätte in Wölnitz, so eine Dorfgaststätte, muss man echt irgendwie über einen Feldweg fahren um dahin zu kommen und dann findet man keinen Parkplatz, aber die machen noch original Lichtenhainer Bier, das auch sauer ist.
Es gab das Grätzer Bier ... das ... eher so rauchig schmeckte, aber auch ein Sauerbier war und natürlich die Berliner Weiße.
Als bekanntester Vertreter dieser Gattung.
Mhmh
Also Grätzer Bier wurde Mitte der 90er das letzte Mal gebraut.
Lichtenhainer gibt es noch eins, Bremer Weiße ist ausgestorben, die Gose wurde jetzt zum Glück wiederbelebt.
Und aber auch Berliner Weiße ist halt ein vom Aussterben bedrohtes Bier.
Kann man
im Restaurant bestellen und gibt's dann irgendwie Soße rein, war das früher auch schon so oder ist das auch so eine Spielart der letzten 10 Jahre?
Also was die Berliner Weiße stirbt ja schon länger aus, also wenn man sich die Zahlen anguckt ging es 1870 ungefähr los mit der Erfindung der mechanischen Kühlung, wenn man Fotos von damals sieht, sieht man Fotos an den Kneipen, wo also steht irgendwie: "Hier wird Weißbier und bayrisch Bier ausgeschänkt"
Und bayrisch Bier war halt das moderne neue Untergärige,
mhmh
Und seitdem ist eigentlich so ein schleichender Tod des Berliner Weißen zu verzeichnen, obwohl Napoleon noch die Berliner Weiße als den Champagner des Nordens gelobt hat ne.
oha
Der saß hier am Kachelofen in der ... letzte Instanz heißt die Kneipe heute Zur letzten Instanz und da hat Berliner Weiße getrunken und fand es toll.
das mit dem Strohhalm was man manchmal sieht ist auf jeden Fall ein schlimmer Werbegag aus den 70ern.
Dann gab es so ein Werbefoto mit Liegestuhl und irgendwie so Schirmchen und Strohhalm in der Berliner Weißen
Mhm
und seitdem gibt es da gelgentlich Strohhalme, also das ist garantiert nicht original.
Verstehe.
Das mit dem Sirup da hab ich mir noch keine entgültige Meinung dazu gebildet.
Also wenn man mit alten Berlinern redet, die erzählen einem dann, die haben ihre Weiße nicht mit Sirup getrunken sondern mit Struppe.
mit Struppe ist ein Korn den man dann noch reinschüttet.
aha
also ein Schnaps.
den man vorher reinschüttet und dann trinkt man es?
Joa, so Molle mit Korn, Korn rein.
mh
und das mit dem Sirup also was man wohl schon tatsächlich auch seit über 100 Jahren macht ist ein Schuss Fruchtsaft dazu...
mhmh
Was auch sehr gut passt, weil so eine Berliner Weiße ist halt ein sehr erfrischendes Getränk, hat ein bisschen was von Zitronenlimonade
Und ... allerdings wenn man sich die belgischen Sauerbiere anguckt, da gibt es die Krieks
das sind Biere wo man, also auch Sauerbiere, wo man dann aber nochmal eine Handvoll Sauerkirschen mit ins Fass wirft und es dann ein Jahr in der Ecke stehen lässt.
also so aus Sauerbieren fruchtige Biere zu machen ist auf jeden Fall was, was also historische Kontinuität hat und schon lange getan wird.
Und ich würde davon ausgehen das auch Berliner Weiße mit Früchten im Fass durchaus üblich waren, und hier getan wurde.
Ja bis das Reinheitsgebot kam, ne das galt halt hier nicht und 1871 im Zuge der also als das Großdeutsche Reich geschaffen wurde unter Bismarck und so
da galt dann plötzlich auch das Reinheitsgebot überall in Deutschland und dann durfte man auch hier in Berlin keine Früchte mehr in seinen Biertank reinschmeißen.
So von...
Ist ja verboten.
ach seufz
Ja
So das heißt wir stellen eigentlich fest ... es gibt gar keine Berliner Weiße mehr?
Also es gibt noch eine, die unter diesem Namen verkauft wird, unter dem Markennamen Kindl, was zu Radeberger gehört, was zu Dr. Öttker gehört.
Aber wo nicht die richtige Weiße wo die nicht die richtige Hefe verwendet wird.
Wo nicht die richtige Hefe verwendet wird und also es ist sogar noch ein  bisschen komplizierter als das also
zweitens war es früher so, dass die Milchsäuregärung und die Hefegärung gemischt stattgefunden hat, das heißt man hatte seinen Bottich mit Würze
und da hat man den Kram reingekippt. ja? und dann hat es vor sich hingegärt und ist sauer geworden...
Also den Kram im Sinne von Hefe und ...?
Hefe und Milchsäure
Und Milchsäurebakterien gleichzeitig.
genau die man dann halt aus die Woche davor aus dem Bottich rausgeholt hat aufgehoben und in den nächsten reingegossen, ja also
mhmh
Einmal die Woche wurde halt dann frisch umgeimpft
... das hat also im selben Fass gegoren und kam dann lebendig in die Flasche, also is in der Flasche gereift, Flaschengärung wie ich das vorhin beschrieben habe.
Ja
Wie man das als Hobbybrauer auch macht.
mhmh
... heutzutage nimmt man getrennte Tanks, da ist also ein Tank da findet die Milchsäuregärung statt und der andere Tank da findet die alkoholische Gärung statt
Also eine Tank die Milchsäurebaktieren, andere Tank die Hefe...
Also man trennt das sozusagen....?
Man trennt das lässt es getrennt vergären und pastorisiert das dann und füllt das dann auf Flaschen, das heißt es lebt auch nicht mehr, wenn es in der Flasche ankommt.
Also in der Flasche wird es erst gemischt?
Genau es wird erst...
50% von jedem oder was?
genau beim Abfüllen wird das erst gemischt. Was natürlich technologisch den Vorteil hat, dass man den Säuregehalt relativ gut kontrollieren kann, was aber dazu führt, dass irgendwie das lebt halt nicht mehr.
Ja und in dem Moment, wo man das tot macht, dann schmeckt es nicht mehr so gut.
mh
Jo
Und was noch dazu kommt, was lange Zeit unbekannt war...
Also durch das also es wird erhitzt?
genau
Aber warum wird es erhitzt? Damit es länger haltbar ist?
mhjaa, weil also in dem Fall Berliner Weiße ist auch so lange haltbar durch die Säure.
Ja, aber warum wird die dann nochmal erhitzt, also...?
Damit die Milchsäurebakterien auch auf jeden Fall tot sind, damit der Säuregehalt nicht weiter steigt in der Flasche.
Und man einen kontrollierten Säuregehalt hat.
Ah... das man sozusagen so ein industrielles Produkt hat,
Genau
Was man in definierte...
Normiertes Produkt.
Klingt es ist zwar scheiße aber es ist zumindest immer gleich scheiße.
Genau der McDonaldsansatz.
ahja
Kriegst du überall den definiert genauso schlechten Burger.
stimmt
Man hasst sich jedes Mal dafür, wenn man sich auf das Spiel einlässt.
Ja aber man weiß genau es wird nicht schlimmer als das.
Ja genau.
Es wird auch nicht besser, aber es wird auch nicht schlimmer.
das ist... ja...
na gut.
Oh weia
Und dann gibt es noch einen Unterschied und für den muss ich jetzt ein bisschen weiter ausholen, nämlich wieder zurück in die Carlsberg-Brauerei.
Die...
Die das mit dem PH-Wert äh...?
Das mit dem PH-Wert und das Reinkultur erfunden haben, also nachdem irgendwann klar war dieser Brei den die Brauer da raus holen.
das ist Hefe und Hefe besteht aus Zellen und irgendwann haben sie unter dem Mikroskop die Zellen gesehen.
Ja
Dann sind sie auf die Idee gekommen, man könne doch eine gleichmäßige Qualität des Produktionsprozesses...
Also das waren die die überhaupt erstmal festgestellt haben, dass das ganze überhaupt so ein ... krasser biologischer Prozess ist, vorher haben sie sich da nie so den Kopf gemacht?
Ich weiß nicht, genau also die haben es auf jeden Fall erforscht, ich weiß nicht ob sie die ersten waren, die erkannt haben, dass Hefe ein Organismus ist der aus Zellen besteht.
mhmh
Auf jeden Fall sind sie als erste auf die Idee gekommen, dass man diese Zellen doch soweit vereinzeln könne, dass man eine einzige Zelle nimmt und die wieder hoch vermehrt.
Damit sozusagen die gesamte Hefe die man ins Bier gibt alles aus der selben Zelle kommt.
Damit man eine definierte Qualität hat, nämlich irgendwie genau diese definierte Hefesorte.
Und nicht immer wieder abnimmt was rausgekommen ist, weil es ja....?
Wo alles mögliche mit drin lebt.
Ja
Eine Reinzellkultur.
das war schon Ende des 19Jhrd.s hat sich bei den ganzen Lagerbrauereien relativ schnell durchgesetzt, aber dann haben die Briten versucht das zu tun.
und haben festgestellt das Bier schmeckt nicht mehr.
Also die haben auch Reinzellkulturen ihrer Hefe gemacht, haben das den Leuten vorgesetzt und die Leute haben gesagt:"Das schmeckt nicht".
Und dann haben sie geforscht und geforscht und geforscht und sind drauf gekommen, dass bei bestimmten britischen Bieren eine weitere Hefe eine Rolle spielt.
Die sie natürlich nach Britannien benannt hatten, haben dann die heißt Brettanomyces.
Und besagte Brettanomyces fühlt sich also insbesondere in alten Holzfässern sehr wohl.
Das ist auch der Grund war warum sie nicht gefunden wurde, die war nicht unbedingt in hohen Konzentrationen drin in der Hefe, die immer von dem einen in das andere gekippt wurde. Sondern die wohnte in den Fässern wo das Bier gereift ist.
mhmh
Und hat dann noch mal einen schon speziellen Geschmack gegeben.
Und da gibt es also ich glaub 1905 ist der Artikel erschienen über die Bretannomyces.
Es wurde dann relativ schnell entdeckt, dass auch die belgischen Biere gerne mal Bretannomyces enthalten, also Orval ist zum Beispiel so ein Bier eins der Trapistenbiere (???) das Bretannomyces enthält.
und Berliner Weiße auch, was aber erst seit Mitte der 80er Jahre bekannt ist.
Der derzeitige Inhaber des Lehrstuhles für Brauereiwesen für Berlin, wir haben ja in Berlin einen von 2 Lehrstühlen weltweit, wo man Brauereiwesen studieren kann.
Einen von zwei weltweit?
Ja
In Berlin?
Warum denn ausgerechnet in Berlin?
Weil es da seit 130 Jahren die Versuchs und Lehranstalt für Brauereiwesen e.V. gibt, so war halt mal ein wichtiger Brauereistandort.
Und warum gibt es, wo ist die andere?
Weihenstefan...
In Bayern...?
In Bayern, natürlich.
Bzw. gibt es mittlerweile noch eine Dritte es gibt nämlich das die Dömenshochschule, die da angeschlossen ist, eine privatwirtschaftliche Hochschule
die aber mehr oder weniger zur Weihenstefan dazu gehört, da krieg ich bestimmt auch Ärger das zu sagen, aber das ist ein Klüngel.
Also es gibt hier in Berlin und es gibt diesen Klüngel in Weihenstefan und Dömens.
Und besagter Professor hat in den 80er Jahren seine Doktorarbeit über die Berliner Weiße geschrieben und die Berliner Weiße analysiert.
Und hat da festgestellt, dass die Brettanomyces also für die Geschmacksbildung einer Berliner Weißen absolut essentiell ist.
So die ist wichtig die gehört da rein, wenn man das weg lässt, schmeckt es nicht.
Und der hat also die die Kindl Weiße, die die es heute noch gibt, die wurde damals schon nach diesem neuen Verfahren hergestellt, als man nämlich noch nicht wusste, dass man auch Brettanomyces ran tun muss, damit es schmeckt.
Wurde dieses Verfahren entwickelt.
Das heißt bei dem, die dachten sie hätten sozusagen die alte Weiße übernommen, haben aber dann quasi diesen Teil... ... übersehen?
Sie haben den wichtigen Teil vergessen, und tatsächlich ist es so, dass die Berliner Weiße bis na im Prinzip bis 2005 die Produktion bei Schultheis (???) dicht gemacht wurde nicht mit Reinkulturen gearbeitet hat, sondern nach dem alten Verfahren "Wir nehmen das aus dem alten Bottich und schütten das in den neuen Bottich.
Wodurch es immer wieder erhalten blieb?
Wodurch es erhalten blieb und wodurch natürlich auch niemand wirklich genau wusste, was da jetzt so alles an Kulturen drin ist... man hat da so eine Vorstellung...
2005 kam dann... kamen die Experten, haben gesagt, ja hier jetzt stellen wir das mal hier auf den modernen Standard um
Ja
Ich fürchte es war noch simpler, es war irgendwie naja so also 2005 hat glaube ich Radeberger die vorletzte Berliner Brauerei gekauft.
Die letzte war Bürgerbräu 2009 oder 2010? Ist noch gar nicht so lange her.
Auf jeden Fall war es die letzte die Berliner Weiße nach der traditionellen Methode hergestellt hatten, dann kamen die Herren Betriebswirtschaftler, haben gesagt irgendwie " der Markt für Berliner Weiße ist sehr gering, also können wir nicht mehr als eine Marke aufrecht erhalten, also nehmen wir die die sich technologisch am leichtesten produzieren lässt.
Und deswegen hat Kindl überlebt, mit dem nicht mehr traditionellen Verfahren.
mhmh
Das heißt 2005 zum Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme dieses Gespräches vor 7 Jahren?
mhh
Muss man immer wieder darauf hinweisen, weil .... wird ja auch noch in 500 Jahren gehört...
Ist die Berliner Weiße as we know it eigentlich gestorben?
Ja, das kann man so sagen.
Es gab diese Biersorte existiert nicht mehr?
Nicht mehr so wie früher genau.
mhmh
Ja
Jetzt hät ich mir hier noch einen Chopin bereitlegen sollen.
dramatische Musik.
Ja genau Q in now (???)
Ja ich hab auf jeden Fall den Professor angeschrieben, weil ich das mal genau wissen wollte und ihn gefragt hatte ob er nicht vielleicht irgendwie er hat da ja geforscht irgendwie noch diese Kulturen rum zu liegen hat...
Warum hat dich denn jetzt ausgerechnet diese Weiße so interessiert?
Na das war halt die regionale Spezialität, man guckt ja irgendwie also ich hab ja in also ich wohn ja in Berlin ja und da guckt man so was gibt es denn hier so für Bier?
Wenn man sich mal anfängt für Bier zu interessieren und die kulturelle Vielfalt bemerkt, interessiert man sich irgendwann natürlich auch für die eigene kulturelle Biergeschichte, die man vor der Nase hat und nicht bloß das was 2000 km weg ist.
und noch diverse andere also diese ganze Gegend hier Brenzlauerberg ...
Jajaja es gibt diverse
diverse .. ist voll mit Brauereien, die Kulturbrauerei, die Bötzowbrauerei sagst du...
genau die ....
In der Landsberger 54 gab es eine Brauerei mit der Versuchs und Lehranstalt, die da so in der Mätzerstraße südlich dieses ganze Viertel war eine Brauerei,
die Geburtstagsclub kennst du bestimmt auch noch, Straße im Friedrichshain.
Jaja
Das war eine Brauerei, so ich hab
mhm
es gibt ein großartiges Buch vom Berliner Unterwelten e.V. über die Geschichte der Brauereien in Berlin die sind durch die Adressbücher durchgelaufen und haben aus 200 Jahren Stadtgeschichte sämtlich jemals verzeichnete Brauereien aus den Adressbüchern raus geholt und dann das was an Ruinen noch existiert fotografiert und ein Buch gemacht, schwer empfehlenswert.
Hammer.
Ja.
So.
mhm
Gibt es alles nicht mehr.
Jedenfalls bin ich zu diesem Professor gelaufen, hab gesagt ob er mal Kulturen für mich hat, und er hat gemeint, hat er nicht, aber er hat ein Tipp für mich, es kann sein, dass die noch leben.
Weil er damals auch aus alten Bierproben versucht die Kulturen zu reaktivieren, die da noch drin waren
und das ist ihm teilweise gelungen, er hat es also geschafft, also insbesondere die Brettanomyces ist sehr sehr zdie wächst sehr langsam aber ist auch fast nicht tot zu kriegen.
überlebt also auch 20 Jahre in einer Flasche bei einem PH-Wert von 3 was also bei so einer Berliner Weißen durchaus üblich ist.
Oder auch mal 30 Jahre.
Die eigentliche Bierhefe stirbt, die ist aber relativ gewöhnlich gewesen.
Da hab ich gedacht ok alte Flaschen alte Flaschen alte Flaschen
Und hab angefangen auf Ebay zu gucken. Und irgendwie tatsächlich taucht gelegentlich auf Ebay eine alte Flasche Berliner Weiße auf, voll.
Wer verkauft sowas?
Leute die ihren Keller ausmisten und feststellen oh ich hab ja noch eine alte Bierflasche, vielleicht ist das ja was für Sammler.
lang lebe Ebay.
Oder so Ostalgiehändler, sowas.
Ja
Und hab jetzt also mittlerweile eine relativ erklägliche Sammlung von Berliner Weißen aus verschiedenen Brauereien.
Also die Ältesten aus den 70ern .. ähm...
Auch Ost und West.
Aber du hast die jetzt nicht gekauft um mal zu trinken und zu schauen wie das früher so geschmeckt hat, sondern du warst so zu sagen auf der Spur dieser Brettanomyce?
Diese spezielle Brettanomyces plus diese Milchsäurebakterien, da muss ich mal gucken ob das mit der Rekonstruktion gelingt.
Also auf jeden Fall das was an dieser Weißen dran ist an Mikroorganismen, ganz vorne die Brettanomyces gefolgt von Milchsäurebakterien gefolgt von der Hefe.
Wobei ich bei der Hefe nicht so eine große Chance sehe.
Ja
Aber ich hab es tatsächlich auch für den Geschmack gekauft. eine Berliner Weiße dadurch dass da diese Milchsäurebakterien und die Brettanomyces drin sind. Die knabbern alles weg, was da noch drin ist.
Also die ganzen Zucker, die normale Hefe nicht abgebaut kriegt,...
Ja
Das wird alles umgewandelt. Da wird dann Milchsäure draus da wird Alkohol draus da werden komische Ester draus die leckeren Geschmack geben,
aber in der Flasche bleibt einfach nichts mehr übrige was biologisch aktiv wäre.
Und das heißt dass die auch extrem haltbar sind?
Die sind extrem haltbar, du kann'st, ich hab eine Flasche getrunken von denen die aus den 70ern stammte.
Eine Flasche aus den 80ern getrunken und die kann man einfach noch trinken, so man hat ein bisschen einen leichten Rossgeschmack vom Kronkorken. Das schmeckt man manchmal ...
... so ein bisschen durch, das lässt sich nicht ganz vermeiden.
hahaha
Aber abgesehen davon sind das halt noch sehr sehr trinkbare Biere, die auch das Geschmacksprofil.
Das heißt sie sind eigeintlich haltbarer als alle anderen Biere?
Ja im Prinzip muss man da kein Haltbarkeitsdatum drauf schreiben, weil die halten sich für immer.
ahh. cool
mh
Abgesehen jetzt vom Kronkorken.
Aber ich hab eine Flasche in einer Champagnerflasche vom Jahre 1987 zum 750 jährigen Jubiläum der Stadt Berlin hat Schultheis (???) in Champagnerflaschen abgefüllt, mit einem richtigen Korken oben drauf, davon hab ich auch eine zu Hause.
aaahhh
Ok die ist aber noch ungeöffnet. Aber eine von den Flaschen habe ich aufgemacht und zwar eine Flasche aus dem VEB Getränkekombinat Berlin, Abteilung Weißbier, was die heutige Kulturbrauerei ist.
Und bin mit einer Freundin, die zufällig gerade ihren Doktor gemacht hat und Zugang zu einem Klasse S2 Sicherheitslabor hatte (geeignet für den Umgang von Gentechnisch modifizierten Organismen)
mhm
Und dann saßen wir da sonntags...
Und wo gibt es so was?
... ich sag jetzt keine Einrichtung, weil wir waren da irgendwie sonntags und nicht mit also... aber es gibt sowas in der Stadt ja...
Ok
und da saßen wir also und haben diese Flasche Bier sorgfältig desinfiziert und dann unterm Abzug geöffnet und auf 2 Gläser verteilt. und diese Gläser auch desinfiziert.
Also desinfiziert von außen erstmal desinfiziert
Erstmal von außen desinfiziert ja.
um sicherzustellen, dass da nichts ist was ...
Das da nichts dran hängt ja.
Wie macht man das?
das ist ... im Prinzip ein geschlossener Kasten, der vorne ein bisschen offen ist,
in dem eine Luftzirkulation stattfindet. Also das wird einfach so wie diese....
Achso wie man Festplatten repariert, so ein Teil was die ganze Zeit absaugt und für frische Luft sorgt.
Genau genau also da ist so eine Luftumwälzung drin, dann hat man vorne so die Möglichkeit reinzufassen.
Also es gibt die mit Handschuhlöchern, das ist extrem unangenehm.
Die mit der Lüftung sind so, dass man einfach durchfassen kann.
Ja
Und durch den Luftstrom im Prinzip alle Partikel abgesaugt werden.
mh
Joa und dann haben wir die Flasche aufgemacht und auf 2 Gläser verteilt.
Den Bodensatz dann fein säuberlich auf Agar ausgestrichen und den Rest des Bieres getrunken.
Auf Agar?
Agar..
Agar agar kennst du bestimmt aus dem Bioladen, für die Veganer die trotzdem Gummibärchen essen wollen.
So ein Pulver was man anrühren kann, dann biledt sich so eine Art Gelee.
aha
Und
agar agar
Agar agar ja....
nie gehört.
Ist ja für Biologen sehr beliebt.
Und was ist das genau?
Es ist ein ... naja so wie Gellatine im wesentlichen, aber nicht aus Kuhfüßen sondern aus Algen.
Ah
Japanischer Fischleim.
Polysacharid.
mh
das Gallerte bilden kann.
Genau
und dann macht man sich so einen Glibber im Prinzip aus Bierwürze und ein bisschen von dem Agarpulver...
also das ist quasi so Bakteriennährstoff an der Stelle?
jjja na der eigentliche Nährstoff ist die Würze die man reintut. Also das ist bloß dass es gelliert.
Der Träger sozusagen.
Genau dass das gelliert und Platten bildet und nicht rumschwabbert.
ah
Und dann macht man sich so eine Art Würzegummibärchen. ... kann man sich das vorstellen.
mh
Also das macht... das Agar sorgt dafür, dass es gallertartig ist. man nimmt Würze, die Würze ist das was die Hefe dann eigentlich frisst.
Ja
dann macht man sich so so Petrischalen draus
mh
Wo man es ein bisschen reingießt, bzw so genannten Schrägagar man nimmt ein Reagenzglas, gießt es schräg rein, so das sich so eine schräge Oberfläche innerhalb von dem Ding bildet und da kann man das dann aufimpfen.
Und da haben wir dann den Bodensatz genommen, haben den auf so eine so eine Agarplatte aufgestrichen und Schrägagar aufgeimpft.
Also Bodensatz das heißt ihr habt die Flaschen komplett ausgegossen und einfach nur noch das was drin war genommen oder ihr habt so direkt in die Flasche reinpipettiert. oder was?
Das ist ja mit Flaschengärung, man kennt das ja von so einer wenn man so ein Hefeweizen hat ja und das stand eine Weile rum, dann gießt man das ein dann ist erstmal klar im Glas und man hat dann unten so einen Bodensatz.
Genau was man dann normalerweise eigentlich aufgeschüttet bevor man aufmacht so weil...
Genau und statt irgendwie aufzuschütteln und es in unsere Gläser zu tun, haben wir es aufgeschüttelt und in ein Reagenzglas getan und von da mit einer Pipette jeweils irgendwie auf die verschiedenen Medien verteilt und ausgestrichen.
Und dann?
naja und dann kam das irgendwie eine Woche in die Wärme und dann ist Pelz gewachsen.
Krass.
Ja
Nach, wie alt war die Flasche?
1989 stand VEB drauf.
Also so alt wie die Einheit?
Joa
Das sind jetzt 23 Jahre.
23 Jahre, eine 23 Jahre alte Flasche Bier
mh
Und da lebte noch was auf dem Boden.
War das überraschend jetzt oder?
Ich war schon beeindruckt, das es auf Anhieb mit der ersten funktioniert hat, also ich hab im Internet gelesen es geht...
Aber wovon haben die sich denn jetzt konkret ernährt? Aber nicht von diesen...
Von gar nichts, die lagen da sozusagen noch lebendig, aber nicht verstoffwechselnd
Nee ich meine auf diesem Teil dann was habt ihr dazu gegeben, dass das äh
Würze...
frisch angemischte Würze alles klar, das worauf sie normalerweise Bock
Wo sie normalerweise Bock drauf haben,
drauf haben.
Aber dann halt mit dem Agar damit es fest ist und schön drauf rum wachsen kann und nicht irgendwie in einer Flüssigkeit rumfließt.
Ah
und dann haben die sich gedacht "na endlich ist hier mal wieder was los hier nach 23 Jahren"
Genau
"geil lass mal hier richtig schön schlemmen"
und dann wachsen sie gleich und ... dann habt ihr dicke Augen gemacht?
Dann haben wir große Augen gekriegt und ich bin grade dabei ein Bier anzusetzen um mit diesen Kulturen tatsächlich mal zu brauen, um mal zu gucken wie es geschmacklich so ist was dabei raus kommt.
Das heißt du hast dann genau das was da vor euren Augen..., wie lang hat das gedauert?
Das hat irgendwie eine Woche oder zwei bis es angewachsen ist und dann hat man was gesehen ja.
Das hat also in dem Labor so vor sich hin...?
Nö ich hab das mit nach Hause genommen und bei mir auf die Heizung gestellt.
Oder mit nach Hause genommen?
ah
Wo andere Leute so eine Katze auf der Heizung liegen haben, hattest du so deine Pilzkultur.
Ja es gibt ...
meine Haushefe...
... im Hobbybrauerforum gibt es einen der nennt sich Hefeknuddler.
Ich merk schon auch in dem Bereich... gibt es echte Hacker mit Liebe zum Detail. Oh mann
Echte Haustiere ja
So das heißt jetzt hast du diese Hefe und und und und und wie lange ich meine musste die jetzt die ganze Zeit mit Würze versorgen, damit die am Leben bleibt?
Die bleiben so eine Weile am Leben und dann muss man sie mal umimpfen auf einen frischen Träger, also alle 3-6 Monate muss man mal das Reagenzglas auspacken, frisch machen, rüberkopieren...
Also ist so ein bisschen wie mit Festplatten die alle 3 Monate kaputt gehen, man muss es regelmäßig umkopieren, damit es
umkopieren, jaja
Am Leben bleibt.
aha
Man kann es auch einfrieren. Ich bin gerade dabei ... also es sind ja mikroskopische Mengen. Ja da hat man so einen kleinen weißen Punkt der da auf dem Agar wächst und man braucht mehr Hefe.
ich hab mir grade eine Magnetröhre geholt, das ist so ein Kästchen wo ein Magnet drin ist der sich dreht.
mhmh
dann hat man so genannten Rührfisch das ist auch ein Magnet. Und dann nimmt man so einen Erlenmeierkolben den man desinfiziert hat, wo dann irgendwie abgekochte Würze drin ist die steril ist.
Und dieser Rührfisch der schwimmt da drin rum und unten dreht sich der Magnet, dann dreht sich der Rührfisch in der Brühe drin
und versucht da grade das mal ein bisschen hochzupäppeln. Also irgendwie aus der winzigen Menge von...
Wieso ist die Würze abgekocht?
Damit sie steril ist, damit nichts anderes da drin wächst, ich will ja das genau das drin wächst, was ich da rein getan habe.
Ah verstehe du hast sozusagen alle andern potentiellen Bakterien etc schon mal die Kante gegeben und..
Genau
Den Rest beziehen wir ...
Hab dann aus meinem, vom Agar sorgfältig so einen kleine weißen Punkt abgehoben und da rein geschmissen.
Und das ist jetzt grade bei mir seit 2 Tagen am durch die Gegend gewirbelt werden und ich hoffe also am Wochenende genügend Hefe zu haben, um erstens was davon einfrieren zu können, damit ich nicht alle drei Monate kopieren muss.
Ja
Und zweitens mal ein Bier davon zu machen.
Was du jetzt bisher noch nicht gemacht hast.
Was ich bis jetzt noch nicht gemacht habe.
Aber du bist jetzt durchaus ... also ... konntet ihr denn da im Labor irgendwie nachweisen worum es sich denn dabei handelt? Also habt ihr euch jetzt diesen Pilz als solchen dann auch mal unterm Mikroskop oder was man sonst so ...
nee das hab ich..
.. heutzutage macht?
Also so wir haben mal das umgeimpft und dann sieht man.
Ah ihr musstet schnell wieder ihr musstet schnell fliehen bevor die Wachen kommen.
ja
Also wenn ich das jetzt hochgepäppelt habe sollte man eigentlich rein olfaktorisch schon feststellen können ob es sich um das Richtige handelt oder nicht.
Aber du bist zuversichtlich?
Ich bin zuversichtlich das hat relativ gut funktioniert.
Und hast du es dem Professor schon erzählt?
Noch nicht nicht.
mh
Und er hat mich ja auch gleich gefragt, er ist ein großer Berliner Weiße Liebhaber und leidet also physisch darunter, dass es keine mehr gibt.
Und so seine 2. Frage war: "Und wollen sie das auch kommerziell herstellen?"
so und wie man dich ja so kennt, .... ... bleibt es ja bei dir dann immer selten beim Hobby, du musst das ja dann immer auch gleich ernst meinen.
Ja
Und willst du jetzt...
Nicht nur Hobbybrauerei sondern eine richtige Brauerei machen?
Ich trage mich gerade ernsthaft mit dem Gedanken ja und hab heute Räume angemietet.
Ein gefliesten Keller in Kreuzberg, also noch nicht etwas wo man wirklich große Kostendeckende Produktion aufziehen könnte, aber zumindest mal etwas wo... man regelmäßig produzieren kann und mal gucken ob es ausreichend Leuten schmeckt, dass man da mehr draus machen kann.
mh
Und
Jetzt hast du hier noch so eine Probe auf dem Tisch stehen, das ist aber Berliner Weiße schon? Oder? Da steht ja Berliner Weiße drauf.
Das ist eine Berliner Weiße, da hab ich allerdings sozusagen nicht die original aus der Flasche rekonstruierten genommen, sondern habe anhand dessen, was der Professor Methner rausgefunden hat, was da für Mikroorganismen drin sein müssen mir die zusammengesammelt.
Also das ist jetzt, durchaus mit ... also die Bierhefe ist eine Korrekte, es handelt sich um eine Deutsche obergärige Hefe.
mhmh
die Milchsäurebakterien und die Brettanomyces stammen allerdings von belgischen Bieren.
Wo wir ja wissen über der den Broyhan gibt es eine Verwandtschaft, allerdings ist das alles 400-500 Jahre her.
ich denke, dass ich es halbwegs getroffen habe, also von dem wie was ich geschmeckt habe von alten Flaschen, geht es schon mal in die richtige Richtung.
Es kann sein , dass die neuen Kulturen jetzt noch überzeugender genau den Punkt treffen oder vielleicht auch nicht, das werde ich rausfinden.
Also eventuell rein biologisch ist es schon das Richtige, es kann sein, dass da noch subtile Unterschiede existieren. Es sollte verdammt nah dran sein an dem wie es gemeint ist.
Das heißt deine Berliner Weiße ist jetzt überhaupt erstmal ... eine richtige Berliner Weiße, weil sie eben diese Brettanomyces wenn auch aus Belgien
genau
enthalten die also so in dieser Art sind? Könnte aber durchaus sein, dass du durch deine archäologische Experimente unter Umständen sogar genau den Style findest, der hier in Berlin mal angesagt war.
Genau, genau noch mal spezifische Unterschiede zu dem jetzt.
mhm
Weiß ich nicht werde ich rausfinden.
Und wenn es funktioniert hab ich noch ein halbes Dutzend Flaschen mehr aus verschiedenen Brauereien aus Ost- und Westberlin.
mh
Gucken was da noch zu holen ist.
Abgefahren.
Ich mach die mal auf.
Mach mal
erster CRE mit Verköstigung hier.
Zeit wurd es ...
Das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt optimal gekühlt.
schnell ins Glas.
Ist aber sehr lebendig...
Ja
Ups aber ich riech es jetzt schon.
riecht bis hier
schon diesen ... sehr sprudelig
mhmh
Und zumindest ist es nicht in die Tastatur gelaufen.
Immerhin
Immerhin...
Sehr sprudelig.
Ja
soll so sein?
Das muss so ja. so lei...
Ist das bei der Kindlweiße auch so?
ja leider nicht sehr schaumstabil, das ist da ...
Stimmt.
Muss ich noch dran arbeiten.
Da ist eigentlich keiner.
genau allerdings so die die amerikanischen Versuche Berliner Weiße nach zu machen, die ich so gesehen habe, sind auch nicht sehr schaumstabil.
aha
wenn man aber historische ... Abbildungen von Biergefäßen anguckt in denen Berliner Weiße ausgeschenkt wurden, dann waren die immer mindestens bis zur Hälfte mit Schaum voll.
Also es muss sich im Original um eine echt doll schäumende Angelegenheit gehandelt haben.
So doll schäumend, dass extra Gläser gebaut wurden, wo man auch die 50-60% Schaum reinkriegt.
Aber was macht denn den Schaum aus? Also was führt denn zu Schaum? Weil es gibt ja auch... Biere wie hatten wir ja schon hier
mh
Das Schwarze...
Und generell eigentlich die ganzen Ales in Britannien sind ja jetzt keine besonderen Schaumproduzenten, da ist dann meistens so ein kleiner dünner Film drauf so, der hält sich dann auch ganz gut. Aber dass es so jetzt mal so richtig sprudelt und zischt oder da wie beim Hefeweizen.. da so . hochklettert wie nichts Gutes?
mhmh
weiß man das? weiß man doch.
Das ist ja das ist aber das ist echt komplexe Chemie. Also da sind verdammt viele Faktoren, die da eine Rolle spielen.
es was mit den Eiweißen zu tun, es hat was damit zu tun wie die Enzyme beim Meischen die Eiweiße umwandeln,
So dann kann können einem Sachen passieren, wie das man sein Glas halt mit Spüli gespült hat, dann gibt es halt kein Schaum.
ja
So ... also was ich jetzt konkret bei diesem Bier tun kann, damit es mehr Schaum hat, das weiß ich noch nicht, das werde ich hoffentlich rausfinden.
Mh
So...
Ja aber,,,....
testen
Also man riecht ganz doll diesen... ... ... ... diesen Milchsäureaspekt irgendwie finde ich.
Ja ja ja
also hat schon was.... .... ...
äh, weiß gar nicht wie soll man das nennen.
So ein bisschen... mh, ich find kein Wort.
Strange, aber lecker.
nu
Sehr lecker... schnief mh
wow aber das ist definitiv, also ich meine das hat jetzt wirklich nichts mit so normalem Bier ... .. zu tun irgendwie.
Nee das ist auch nicht so gemeint...
also, das ist wirklich weit weg von dem ... Pils eigentlich, aber es ist ich mein diese Berliner Weiße die man jetzt hier so, diese Kindlweiße?
Die ist schon bisschen dressiert. also ...
Die ist doch bieriger oder nicht...?
Die ist ein bisschen bieriger also bei der ist jetzt sehr sehr wenig Hopfen drin, also im Prinzip schmeckst du kein Hopfen durch.
Und die die Berliner Kindlweiße die ist schon ein bisschen hopfiger und hat auch eine sehr gezähmte Säure.
3% Alkohol
Ja
Merkt man gar nicht.
Aber sehr frisch!
Jaja ist ein Sommerbier auf jeden Fall.
Also wenn die Sonne richtig knallt und man eh kein Bier trinken kann, weil man nach einem betrunken ist.
Ja, dann nimmt man sich ne Weiße
mhh
und ...
dieses so ein bisschen Zitronenlimo-mäßige...
genau das ist der Effekt, genau ja?
Es erklärt warum Leute das Bedürfnis haben da Sirup reinzuschütten, weil es passte einfach, es passt dass man da Frucht dazu kombiniert.
mhmh um das Saure noch ein bisschen zu ... ... kompensieren und...
Ja wobei es auch Leute die auf das Saure stehen.
Ja ich find das auch total lecker, also ich wär jetzt auch so schon total glücklich.
Ey voll lecker, Andreas.
Du machst lecker Bier hier.
Freut mich.
Ja ist total cool.
Hübschen Aufkleber hast du auch drauf hier.
Bogkbier heißt das da nämlich jetzt.
Genau
Bogkbier Privatbrauerei demnächst in ihrem Kühlregal, aber da sind wir noch weit von entfernt oder?
Da sind wir noch ein bisschen von entfernt ja,
Also ich hoffe dass ich demnächst ähm,,, also ausreichend produziere damit mehr davon da ist als ich selber wegtrinke.
Und dann kann man auch mal darüber nachdenken, das unters Volk zu bringen.
Wow also ich nehm schon mal eine Kiste.
Sehr gut
Ich meine das ist jetzt auch wieder nur so ein 20 Liter Produktionseinheit gewesen?
Das war eine 20 Liter Produktionseinheit, mit dem Equipment was ich jetzt habe, wenn ich mir ein neues Gärfass besorge, dann komme ich auf so 36 Liter pro Batch (???).
mhmh
... dann kann man noch ein bisschen rumtricksen, dass man das ein bisschen stärker einbraut also mit einem höheren Zuckergehalt und dann im Gärfass nochmal verdünnt.
bei Berliner Weiße auch nicht ungewöhnlich gewesen, dass es vor dem Abfüllen in den Flaschen verdünnt wird, also nach der Hauptgärung.
mhmh
... aber mehr so aus ... mehr als 50 Liter pro Brauvorgang komm ich damit auch nicht.
mh
So und damit trägt sich das natürlich noch nicht, also das ist jetzt erstmal so mal ein bisschen mehr machen, damit auch die Freunde die was trinken wollen versorgt sind.
Dann mal gucken wie es dann weitergeht.
mh
Also ich bestell schon mal ein so...
Sehr gut...
Will und die ich meine die ist jetzt im Prinzip, ja die ist nicht geöffnet würde die sich im Prinzip auch ewig halten?
Unbegrenzt ja...
unbegrenzt.
Unbegrenzt bis der Deckel durchrostet.
mh
Und das tut er von außen, also solange du sie kühl und trocken lagerst...
toll
mhmh
Was ist denn so mit diesen Zwischendingern also ich mein was wir noch gar nicht erwähnt haben, es gibt ja auch Malzbier?
mh
Was ja ... kein Alkohol hat, ... wo zweigt das Malzbier jetzt vom Bier ab?
Ähm... ... Im Wesentlichen, also es gibt den klassischen Ansatz und den modernen Ansatz.
Der klassische Ansatz ist eine Hefe zu nehmen, die nur 5-10 % der enthaltenen Zucker abbaut ... und der moderne Ansatz ist es einfach zu pastorisieren und auf Flaschen zu füllen.
Also im Prinzip ist ein Malzbier... fertige Bierwürze, die nicht vergoren wird.
Gar nicht?
Gar nicht.
Und das ist das ganze Geheimnis.
Und einzige Frage ist: Wie kommt das Blubber ins Malzbier?
Und da gibt es halt den klassischen Weg, indem man spezielle Hefen nimmt, die nur einen ganz ganz geringen Teil der Zucker überhaupt umsetzen können, aber gerade so genug, als dass es Blubber gibt.
Und der moderne Ansatz man...
Und da aber auch nicht zwingend Alkohol erzeugen oder?
Ein bisschen schon, also tatsächlich enthalten traditionelle Malzbiere eine geringe Menge Alkohol.
mhmh
Also auch die sogenannten alkoholfreien Biere enthalten bis zu 0,5% Alkohol. Ne muss man wissen.
So da gibt es ganz selten mal welche, die tatsächlich alkoholfrei sind.
Ja
Und der moderne Weg Malzbier her zu stellen, ist einfach eine Bierwürze zu machen und dann einen Tank zu nehmen und dann einfach CO2 unter Druck drauf zu tun, bis es CO2 sich drin löst und blubbert.
Also Malzbier ist eigentlich normale Bierwürze?
Im Prinzip ist es unvergorene Bierwürze ja.
mh
Und das schmeckt auch so wie eine normale Würze so schmeckt oder ist schon darauf getrimmt, dass es da nicht weiter geht?
Es ist schon bisschen drauf getrimmt, so der Hopfenanteil
Weil ist ja auch sehr...
wird zum Beispiel in der Regel sehr gering gehalten.
Und es ist recht süß.
Ja
Also da ist dann viel...
mhmh
naja klar, das sind halt die ganzen Zucker, die dann gar nicht umge... also das ist sozusagen zwangsläufig so süß, weil es halt noch nicht in
genau
Alkohol überführt wurde und deswegen ist das so ein (tief einatmen) kinderkompatibles Getränk angeblich. ... aha
mh
Und wie läuft das mit dem alkoholfreien Bier?
da wird der Alkohol auf verschiedenen Wegen rausextrahiert, also durch irgendwelchen Osmosekram Membran, also technisch aufwändige Verfahren.
Ein alkoholfreies Bier kriegt man zu Hause nicht produziert, da braucht man Großtechnik für.
Das heißt... der Alkohol entsteht schon eigentlich genauso...
mhmh
Nur dass man ihn danach wieder rausholt?
Genau, das ist das Verfahren.
Mh
und wie stehst du so zu alkoholfreiem Bier?
Oh pf es gibt manchmal welche die sind ganz lecker, also vom ,.... Neumarkter Lammsbräu gibt es ein dunkles Weizenbier alkoholfrei, was sehr lecker schmeckt, was aber auch ein bisschen in Richtung Malzbier geht.
Neumarkter Lammsbräu das ist dieses Biobier oder?
Das ist Biobier, die haben als eine der ersten Brauereien mit Biobier angefangen.
Machen meiner Meinung nach auch so ziemlich das beste Pils, was man kriegen kann.
das äh
Also überhaupt?
Ja so insgesamt, so Weltmarktführer.
Qualitativer Weltmarktführer?
Ja
die bauen auch ihren eigenen Hopfen an. Also sie haben angefangen damit, weil es keinen Biohopfen gab und haben jetzt aus der Not eine Tugend gemacht und haben weiter ihren eigenen Hopfen.
mhmh
Und haben auch eine sehr interessante Produktpalette, also da gibt es... die experimentieren viel.
Find ich eine sehr nette Brauerei.
Aus der Oberpfalz.
mhmh
und Bio halt, weil sie ihre ganzen Zutaten quasi aus biologischer Landwirtschaft aus ökologischen Landbau heraus erzeugen.
genau genau.
Macht das was aus oder ist das nur gut für das Gewissen?
pffff
Also .... ich glaube mittlerweile ist es so, dass man auch biologisch erzeugte Lebensmittel kaufen kann, die eher industriell produziert wurden, nicht so gut schmecken.
Aber eine ganze Zeit war es halt so, dass Bio nur handwerklich ging und handwerklich heißt: ist dann auch immer größere Lebensmittelqualität.
Und also beim Neumarkter Lammsbräu ist es nach wie vor so, das ist einfach ein verdammt gutes Bier.
mh
Oh deutsche Biertradition da müssen wir eigentlich noch die Zoiglbiere erwähnen.
Die was?
Zoigl Z O I G L
mhmh
es ist in ländlichen Regionen in Süddeutschland verbreitet.
Da gibt es einen Kommunenbräuhaus, also sozusagen alle Dorfbewohner oder Kleinstädter haben zusammengelegt und haben sich ein Brauhaus gebaut.
Und dann wird regelmäßig gemeinschaftlich in dem Brauhaus gebraut.
Und dann nimmt jeder sozusagen sein Anteil der Würze mit nach Hause, stellt die bei sich in den Keller und macht da zu Hause Bier draus.
mh
Also es ist insbesondere faszinierend, weil die... also es gibt einige die wirklich noch traditionell arbeiten, das sind dann Brauereien die sind halt 200 300 Jahre alt, die haben noch nie in ihrem Leben irgendwas außer Heißwasser zum Putzen gesehen.
Gibt es Fotos von alten Mütterchen im Kopftuch die auf offenen Pferdewagen die Würze von dem einen Eimer in den andern Eimer umschütten.
So wenn man sich das sozusagen mit nach modernen Maßstäben anguckt, fragt man sich so: "Oh wie kann das jemals nicht infiziert sein, ja wie kann da jemals Bier bei rauskommen und nicht einfach das irgendwie nach 3 Tagen schlecht werden?"
Und ich glaub die Antwort darauf ist einfach, dass die ausreichend alte Kulturen haben, die so optimal auf diese Lebensbedingung abgestimmt sind, nämlich auf genau die Würze die da produziert wird,
dass die einfach schneller als alles Andere über das Bier herfallen und es quasi in Alkohol umwandeln bevor irgendein anderer ohne das das auch nur ne Chance hat dran rumzuknabbern.
Ah verstehe.
Sind einfach fixer.
sind einfach Fixer, sozusagen durch natürliche Auslese...
tehe
ausgewählte...
mh
Wie muss man denn jetzt so dieses diesen ganzen Hobby ... ... bereich im Bierbrauen ... einschätzen, also ich meine wenn ich ... richtig erinnere, hast du ja vorhin gesagt so in USA gab es das gibt es diesen Notstand ja schon länger und der tritt jetzt hier eigentlich erst langsam ein.
mhmh
Aber ich hör da jetzt so ein bisschen raus, dass sich hier jetzt auch so eine Bierbrauerbewegung auf den Marsch macht um... beyond the backs (???) zu sein?
Genau, der Widerstand gegen das Industriebier formiert sich grade.
Mhmh
neue Leute die dazu kommen können vergleichsweise einfach heutzutage a) lernen und b) die Zutaten beschaffen.
Ja
Und das kombiniert mit dem ... .. existierenden Leidensdruck... ...
und da muss man sich ja auch als Hobbybrauer lange lange anstrengen bis man so ein Bier machen kann.
Aber ... wenn man in den normalen Supermarkt irgendwo in der Pampa läuft, da gibt es dann irgendwie keine Ahnung Becks und Öttinger und irgendwie wenn man großes Glück hat gibt es auch noch Warsteiner und das war es dann dann hört es auf.
Und aber so die richtig guten sind auch in Deutschland schwierig zu kriegen.
Die ganzen kleinen Mittelständischen handwerklichen Brauereien haben auch arg mit dem Überleben zu kämpfen.
Weil .... so das Biergeschäft wird oftmals über die Masse gemacht. Ja die Leute wollen für 5,99€ einen Kasten Bier kaufen.
... wo ich mich frage wie das gehen soll? Ja also ich gebe mehr als 5,99€ für ein Kasten Bier allein für die Rohstoffe aus und...
mhmh
Wenn man so 100 Tonnen Malz am Stück einkauft ist natürlich der Einkaufspreis ein besserer, als wenn man bloß 25 kg kauft oder 3.
Ich denke ich meine viele Leute benutzen wahrscheinlich Bier auch einfach mehr so als Alkoholtransport ja also dieses...
meinen vielleicht zu glauben, da einem Genuss zu erliegen, aber wahrscheinlich ist es doch eher so der Alkoholimport der da im Vordergrund steht.
sind ja auch bereit da ihr Geld auszugeben, wenn man jetzt mal so mit einem Weinmaßstab da ran geht,
mh
wo es ja sehr viel akzeptierter ist, dass guter Wein. ..
Eine Flasche auch mal 20 € kosten kann.
Genau, sowas gibt es ja eigentlich im Bierbereich gar nicht oder?
Also ich meine gibt es so Bierläden wo man reingeht und sagt so hier hier Berliner Weiße von 1975 und so gut abgehangen und so garantiert kein Zucker mehr drin
schmeckt trotzdem geil?
Tatsächlich wirst du glaube ich in meinem Keller die größte Konzentration historischer Berliner Weiße überhaupt auf diesem Planeten finden.
In amiland tatsächlich mittlerweile sehr viel akzeptierter, also da... kannst du eigentlich in jeder größeren Stadt in den Laden gehen, wo es dann die guten Biere gibt.
Und da ist dann auch akzeptiert, dass eine Flasche Bier mal 5 Dollar 10 Dollar 20 Dollar kostet.
Mhmh
Die auch so Sachen haben es gibt von Schneider - Schneider ist eine Weißbierbrauerei - nen
nen Doppelbock einen Eisbock der ganz hervorragend ist, wo dann auch schon mal die Flasche 4-5 € kostet.
Also das meiste davon geht nach USA, weil einfach hier der Markt  nicht da ist, aber wenn man richtig doll danach sucht findet man das hier auch schon.
Aber ... ganz allgemein ist so das Verständnis für Bier als Genussmittel wenig ausgeprägt.
Also ich saß in Hotels ... ja gibt es irgendwie 400 verschiedene Sorten Wein, riesen Weinkeller, irgendwie 30 verschiedene Sorten edelster Schnäpse und ... dann gibt es Becks und Franziskaner....
Wo ich mir so vorkomme wie in der Mitropa,
Da gibt es auch Becks und Franziskaner.
Und dann hab ich mir natürlich nicht nehmen lassen den gastronomischen Leiter des Hauses ranzuzitieren war immerhin ein besseres Haus. Und ihn mal darauf anzusprechen, wie er das denn also ob er sich nicht schämt so ein Bier zu servieren.
Wo er sich dann auch ein bisschen gewunden hat und erstmal den Punkt nicht verstanden hat.
Ja
Dan habe ich am nächsten Tag einen Maibock von mir mitgebracht dann hat er den Punkt verstanden.
Ah du hast ihn einfach mal testen lassen?
Ich hab ihn einfach mal kosten lassen, dann hat er auch irgendwie verstanden wovon ich rede.
Ja
Und meinte dann aber naja ist schwierig und irgendwie so Leitung des Hauses und langfristige Lieferverträge mit dem Bierlieferanten und so ging alles nicht.
Oder irgendwie hier in Berlin in der Pappelallee in einer Bar gewesen Becketts Kopf die wirklich ganz hervorragende Cocktails servieren mit erlesendsten Zutaten.
Und ... dann war glaub ich, was war es, .... Warsteiner auf der Karte also Bier. So.
Ich glaub die wohl dich aber auch mehr so in die Richtung Cocktail drängen. also wenn du unbedingt ein Bier haben willst so...
Ja das ist ja okay, das find ich ja okay das ich irgendwie, aber dann sollen sie gar kein Bier auf der Karte haben.
Ja da hast du recht.
Also dann irgendwie anstatt ein schlechtes Bier zu ... sie schämen sich halt noch nicht davon ein schlechtes Bier zu servieren und das finde ich das geht nicht so.
Ja ja also wenn man irgendwie an seine Genussmittel einen gewissen Maßstab hat, dann sollte man den auch anwenden.
Und sagen irgendwie dann gibt es bei uns halt kein Bier und wenn es ein Bier gibt dann gibt es auch ein wirklich gutes Bier so.
mh
Und was müsste man da nehmen?
So an guten Bieren?
Naja ich meine jetzt wird es natürlich wieder schwierig, aber...
Also das dieses Feldbräu, was ich hier gerade trinke, würde ich zum Beispiel also... in seiner Klasse nämlich ein fränkisches dunkles Bier schon ganz weit vorne finden.
das bei Pils das Lammsbräu hab ich schon erwähnt.
mhmh
ich find das Tannenzäpfle auch noch ein sehr trinkbares Bier.
was gibt es da noch?
Hefeweizen ist denn das dein ...?
Hefeweizen, Hefeweizen gibt es auch ein paar Gute.
Ich bin großer Freund von Hefeweizen.
Schneider macht ein sehr gutes Hefeweizen, die sind auch die die sich am ehesten trauen zu experimentieren, also von Schneider gibt es tatsächlich irgendwie mal wieder nur für den amerikanischen Exportmarkt es sei denn man weiß wo man bohrt.
Aber tatsächlich mittlerweile eine ganze Reihe von Variationen zum Thema Weizenbier.
Also zum Beispiel ein stärker gehopftes Weizenbier, wo man den Hopfen durchschmeckt, was man ja normalerweise nicht tut
Ja
Oder das als als Weizenbock oder Doppelbock oder sogar Eisbock...
Beim Eisbock wird also das Bier gefroren und dann filtert man die Eiskristalle raus. und dann findet sich sozusagen der Geschmack mit dem Alkohol noch flüssig in Lösung, weil Alkohol ja einen geringeren Gefrierpunkt hat.
mh
Dann kommt man auf ein Bier mit 12% was also echt eher Likör ist als Bier.
Wird das Wasser sozusagen, der Wasseranteil herausgefroren und dann entfernt und äh
genau genau genau
Ah
und ... was gibt es noch an da natürlich irgendwie was es an internationalen Bieren gibt, also
so ich finde, wenn man Bier anbietet und gut sortiert sein will, dann kommt man nicht drum rum ein Porter dabei zu haben, da kommt man nicht drum rum ein IPA da zu haben.
die Sauerbierfraktion muss auf jeden Fall vertreten sein, also wahrscheinlich ein belgisches, weil hier gibt es ja nicht mehr so viel
Vielleicht demnächst mehr.
ja
Also so ein Bogkbier ...
mh
Und kriegt dann so ein ...
Da braucht man auch kein Sirup mehr rein zu tun, weil der ist quasi schon da?
Das ist nicht mehr süß, das ist dann nicht mehr süß. Es schmeckt zwar fruchtig und aromatisch, aber es ist nicht mehr süß.
Ok
Es gibt das dann...
Stimmt weil vom Zucker nichts übrig bleibt.
Vom Zucker bleibt nichts übrig, das wird alles weggeknabbert.
Dann ... was gibt es noch was unbedingt vertreten sein muss? ähm
Auf jeden Fall so ein klassisches britisches Ale sollte man haben und wenn es irgendwie so ein Fullers ist, was irgendwie halbwegs ein Standardbier ist aber noch erträglich.
es gibt ja mittlerweile auch Biersommeliere, also so wie es Weinsommeliere gibt, die einem den Wein empfehlen zum Essen und die eine eigene Ausbildung machen um Wein zu schmecken.
Und irgendwie die Einkaufsberatung und zu machen, gibt es Biersommeliere.
Also einen Diplomstudiengang über 2 Jahre, wo man lernt, wie Bier schmeckt.
also das ist die Empfehlung wäre dann, also wenn man wirklich gehoben kulinarisch was mit Bier machen möchte, sollte man auf jeden Fall sich einen Biersommelier suchen und dann mal ausführlich beraten lassen,
weil dann kann man auch als Koch sagen: "Ich koche das und das und das und das" und lassen sich die passenden Biere dazu raussuchen lassen
Es gibt richtig als Beruf jemanden der quasi Bierberater ist?
Ja.
Und da muss man 2 Jahre für Ausbildung machen?
2 Jahre lang saufen.
Ja.
Also es ist so eine seltsame Branche, auf der Homepage der Fakultät für Brauereiwesen in Berlin steht auch: "Kommen Sie doch mal auf ein Bier bei uns vorbei"
Also ich finde es erstaunlich, dass also wirklich hier in Berlin so so eine Hochburg des Brauereiwesens gibt.
Und ich meine ... ist denn das scheint mir aber jetzt kein besonders gefragter Beruf mehr zu sein, Brauer, weil das ja irgendwie....
keine Ahnung, in der Industrie... alle schon dermaßen durchoptimiert ist.
Ja die Leute....
Also die Leute gehen natürlich größtenteils ins Ausland hinterher mit ihrem Studium und ähm
Ah verstehe
Also man hat irgendwie eine größere Chance in Südamerika oder in Asien irgendwo eine Brauerei aufzumachen als hier in Berlin.
So der Jobmarkt für Brauer sieht nicht so rosig aus grade, wenn man nicht irgendwie selber...
Aber das ist sozusagen die optimale Ausbildung, wenn man sowieso auswandern möchte?
Das schon, also wenn man so ein deutsches Bierbrauerdiplom hat, dann kann man eigentlich wo man hin will in der Welt und sagen "schönen guten Tag ich bin Bierbrauer gebt mir einen Job" und das klappt einigermaßen, je weiter weg desto besser.
Aber es gibt ja hier auch, aber auch in Deutschland immer wieder mal so Neugründungen, ne, also hier bei Potsdam wie heißen die Jungs noch gleich?
die Braumanufaktur?
Genau
Forsthaus Templin
Mhmh
Ohja die müssen wir auf jeden Fall erwähnen. So irgendwie mal Lokalpatriotisch die örtlichen Brauereien die was taugen erwähnen.
Ja
die finde ich ganz weit vorne.
Es ist wunderschön gelegen am Templiner See ein Stückchen südlich von Potsdam in einem alten Forsthaus.
machen Biobiere... auch handwerklich, also mit nicht besonders großen Volumina, man kann da wunderschön hingehen essen und trinken.
Und die machen ordentliches Bier.
das Eschenbräu finde ich in Berlin noch sehr erwähnenswert.
Warte mal wo du das gerade erwähnt hast, da will ich auch gleich nochmal verweisen, das Küchenradio hat da auch mal ein eine Sendung gemacht über das Forsthaus Templin...
So mit....
Liverundgang durch die Brauerei dort vor Ort.
Man kann da auch...
Küchenradio 136
Man kann auch Lehrgänge machen, also wenn man mal irgendwie, also wenn man selber brauen möchte und sich das nicht so aus der Kalten in seiner eigenen Küche traut,
Kann man da auch mal hin und mal einen Samstag sich das von den Profis zeigen lassen, wie das geht mit dem Brauen.
mhmh
Ok was war das andere was du jetzt grade erwähnt hattest?
Das Eschenbräu würd ich gern noch erwähnen.
mhmh
Weil das ist im Wedding ähm
Ist ja so eine Art Biergarten, also ist natürlich Weddingstyle mitten in einem Neubaublock und in einer Baracke aber es hat Bäume und es hat gutes Bier.
Und der Braumeister da ist auch ... freundlich aufgeschlossen und hilfsbereit, also wir haben da ein Hobbybrauertreffen gemacht und wir hatten bei einigen Braukneipen angefragt und es fanden immer schwierig so eigenes Bier mitbringen und so naja nee das geht nicht.
Wir zahlen auch Korkgeld.
Nee nee das geht alles nicht.
Und da irgendwie musste ich gar nicht drüber reden, also ich meinte irgendwie Brauertreffen, meinte er "ja komm vorbei kein Problem kein Ding" "Wir bringen unser eigenes Bier mit" "Jaja macht mal bin ich gespannt drauf".
Hinterher haben wir für sein Bier nicht mal was bezahlt, weil ihm unser Bier so gut geschmeckt hat.
Also total großartiger Mensch, hat auch eine sehr schöne Destille im Gastraum zu stehen.
Mit ... also wenn man destillieren will.. ist das ja alles nochmal komplizierter.
mhmh
Und er hat da also so eine große Destille, wo die Hälfte in Plexiglas eingebaut ist, mit dicken Vorhängeschlössern davor,
vom Zoll wo ... original noch drauf steht "Deutsches Reich" und ein Adler.
So als diese Schlösser...
Und da gibt es also auch regelmäßig wechselnde Biere. Der bemüht sich immer um Abwechslung und der macht gutes Bier und das ist halt alles sehr ... äh... sehr selfmade, also auch die Anlage ist so zusammengebaut.
Find ich ... ja ...
Aber wahrscheinlich gibt es in Franken noch eine ganze ganze ganze Touristenstraße entlang ... mein da jedes dritte Haus eine Brauerei...
Ja genau, aber die guten Biere sind da wo die Touristen nicht lang kommen, also die den guten Stuff behalten sie für sich selber. Das wird dann halt irgendwie im Ort getrunken und noch 2 Kneipen im Nachbarort beliefert und dann war es das.
Und wenn man mal richtig doll Glück hat und irgendwie weiß wonach man sucht, kriegt man mal so ein Fässchen geliefert nach Berlin, aber...
genau oder man bestellt sich hier so eine Kiste, wie ... das was du da grade gehabt hast hier bei hiergibtsbier.de und dann
genau
Sowas...
Wo wir bei den Franken sind das muss ich auch noch erwähnen, es gibt einen fränkischen Biergarten in Berlin. Die Republik Frank und Frei.
Wird von Exilfranken betrieben.
Ganz ganz großartig ist direkt neben dem Sage Club
Ja
haben einen alten roten Doppelstockbus als Regenlocation, ansonsten halt Bierbänke draußen.
mhmh
Gibt auch ganz hervorragende Bratwurst und ähnliche Leckereien und natürlich nur fränkisches Bier.
Spalter Hell haben sie Spalt zweitgrößte Hopfenanbauregion der Welt.
mh
Und das Bier, dass da lokal gebraut wird, das Spalter gibt es da und dann gibt es aus Nürnberg das ... Schanzenbräu ein rotes Bier.
Sehr gut und irgendwie so 2 3 verschiedene Flaschenbiere
Ich glaub Gutmann Gutmannhefe ist auch noch ein gutes, Unertl ist noch gut wo wir schon bei guten Hefeweizen sind.
Das Schlimme ist egal wie viel wir jetzt aufzählen,...
mh es werden sich immer Leute auf den Schlips getreten fühlen.
Auf jeden Fall weil es noch 100 oder 1000 de weitere Tipps gibt.
Ja,
Aber der...
Aber du hast hier so eine Dropbox hab ich gehört, man kann dir Dinge schicken und die landen hier.
haha du meinst jetzt so physisch?
Jaja
ja gut das auch, ansonsten Tipps kann man natürlich auch in die Kommentare schmeißen. Sollen ja auch noch andere etwas davon
haben. so
Also ich muss auch noch sagen, diese fränkische Bierkiste hat mich auch so ein bisschen so auf den Film gebracht. Mein ich glaub das war dann auch so ein bisschen der Punkt wo ich dann beschlossen habe, dass wir uns jetzt hier mal zusammensetzen müssen, weil das dann doch irgendwie so ein bisschen...
Wie du schon sagst, so ein bisschen so ein verkannter Stil ist, man sitzt eigentlich hier in Deutschland auf so einem Goldschatz und ist sich dessen nicht so richtig bewusst, was damit eigentlich gerade passiert.
Genau die meisten Leute sind...
Ich meine wenn Brauereien speziale Biersorten machen für den Export, sollte man wirklich...
mh mh ... ja viele Leute sind unheimlich stolz auf das Deutsche Bier und haben nie ein gutes deutsches Bier getrunken.
Ja das scheint mir fast so.
mh
Müssen wir was dran tun.
Ja haben wir jetzt gemacht, haben wir einen epischen CRE aufgenommen, ich glaube wir haben gerade den Längenrekord gebrochen...
Ähm,... hast du noch was auf dem ... Herzen?
Was wir noch nicht erwähnt haben?
Naja wir haben besitmmt tonneweise Zeug nicht erwähnt.
Tonnenweise.
Eben wusste ich auch noch was, jetzt hab ich es vergessen.
Ja ich meine man kann natürlich hier viel philosophieren über das richtige Holz beim Fass und geschichtliche Details...
Aber uns fällt jetzt nichts mehr ein oder?
Ein Ausgehtipp hab ich noch irgendwie ok es ist ein bisschen teurer, weil am Gendarmenmarkt, aber da gibt es das Augustiner.
Die erwähnten die ihr Malz selber machen und da wird jeden Tag um 18 Uhr ein Holzfass angeschlagen.
Und das ist ein Erlebnis wert um 17:30 Uhr zu kommen und einmal genau dasselbe Bier aus einem Metallfass und dann hinterher aus dem Holzfass zu trinken und einfach festzustellen, was das für ein Unterschied ist, wenn das Bier noch lebt.
mh
Ozapft ist.
Genau
Andreas... vielen Dank.
Tim... war mir ein Vergnügen.
Das war ... eine epische Ausgabe hier...
mhmh
Von CRE... und jetzt ist sie vorbei
Ja
Und ja genau und all ihr spitzfindigen Bierkenner, die jetzt schon die ganze Zeit auf dem Sitz herumrutschen und dieses mit "Oh das haben sie aber nicht zu 100% sondern nur zu 99,97% genau erklärt.
Fühlt euch eingeladen uns auf zu klären hier und alle anderen auch in den Kommentaren und da noch ein paar Tipps und sonstige Hinweise zu geben.
Vielleicht eins du hattest jetzt so ein paar Sachen schon erwähnt, aber so was sind denn so die angesagten Internetadressen, wo man mal vorbeischauen sollte zum Thema "Ich brau mir was"?
Also was sind so die anerkannten Ressourcen oder...?
Also der zentrale Anlaufpunkt in Deutschland ist eigentlich das Hobbybrauerforum unter hobbybrauer.de
mhmh
Und da werden sie geholfen. also das...
das reicht schon?
das muss man nicht wissen.
Das reicht schon.
das ist ein Forum?
ist ein Forum .
mhmh
Brau-FAQ gibt es hier.
Brautools download ach echt? ... kann man sich Bier auch runterladen?
Oder aus den Hopfengarben wie bitter das Bier wird oder lauter so Sachen.
Verstehe.
Wie welche Farbe dein Bier haben wird und also man es gibt da viel was man berechnen können muss.
mh
CO2 Gehalt.
Verstehe...
Na jut,
ja
Und sich austauschen und mit andern Leuten reden, weil am Ende ist natürlich Bier vorallem ein Kommunikationsinstrument.
Genau
Das war es. Bis bald. Viel Spaß
Tschüß